vérité d'abord les conditions d'accès au
stade et les raisons qui ont conduit au
blocage la dispersion de la foule par
l'usagé des gaz lacrymogènes le ministre
a insisté la semaine dernière sur
l'ampleur d'une fraude aux billets qui
selon lui n'était pas prévisible
et également sur le nombre de supporters
singulièrement de l'équipe de liverpool
qu'il a semble-t-il aurait été assez
inattendue alors finalement plusieurs
questions demeurent sur cette
imprévisibilité allégués et sur les
chiffres qui devront être
incontestablement mieux établi à 7 égale
les remontées d'informations que que
vous disposiez naturellement on imagine
on imagine bien en particulier sur la
grève des transports la note du service
de renseignement du 25 mai dernier sur
la présence de supporters les billets
d'accès sous forme papier vous ont
conduit légitimement d'ailleurs à
mobiliser et des forces de police en en
quantité importante pour organiser cet
événement la question que nous nous
sommes posée depuis la semaine dernière
c'est quelle doctrine d'emploi de ces
forces de police quelle organisation
pour répondre aux à la situation telle
qu'elle s'est déroulée mais telle
qu'elle était probablement en partie
prévisible
la question qui vient immédiatement
après c est qui surprend un peu tout le
monde sait que face à un public qui
finalement était un public j'allais dire
passif au bon sens du terme calme je
dirais plutôt familiale on a vu l'usagé
de bombes lacrymogènes et des images à
la télévision qui ont circulé de gens
qui attendaient patiemment et qui ont
qui ont pris un coup de gaz lacrymogènes
sincèrement
on a pas on comprend pas donc on a
besoin de comprendre c'est vraiment ce
qui s'est passé et on s'interroge aussi
sur le deuxième sujet c'est la séquence
qui relève du maintien de l'ordre mais
plutôt de la sécurité publique
beaucoup datent semble-t-il d'agression
eu lieu autour du stade on entend les
chiffres de entre 400 et 500 personnes
auraient agressé des supporters en tous
les cas des gens qui veut se rendre au
stade en leur faisant les poches sont
les agressions physiquement en tous les
cas alors en et entraîne des
comportements délinquants sont tout
simplement dix ans les mots dès qu'ils
sont
mais finalement on en a peu parlé en
tous les cas on a peu d'éléments sur
cette situation là à la fois sur la
gestion de situation est à la fois sur
les suites qui ont été données et
peut-être même sur leur anticipation
nous ne comprenons pas bien ce qui s'est
passé la situation ne peut pas être
simplement celle nous semble-t-il de
supporters qui ont des difficultés à
accéder au stade mais celle de
délinquants qui
agressent les supporters doit être
parfaitement éclaircis nous avons besoin
de comprendre cela aussi la question qui
en découlent et je m'arrêterai là ces
cas était le dispositif de sécurité
publique prévue alors à l'issue du match
estimez-vous qu'il a fonctionné et que
les améliorations possibles avez vous
envisagé pour d'autres événements de
cette ampleur nous savons qu'il y en
aura évidemment la coupe du monde de
rugby l'année prochaine bien sûr les
jeux olympiques en 2024 et paralympiques
peut-être même d'autres événements
sportifs ou d'autres natures qui auront
lieu au stade de france nous interroge
je préfère moi j'en ai terminé avec
le souhait de vous entendre et je
voudrais simplement vous rappelez vous
dire par vous rappelez vous dire que
nous ne sommes pas ici
contre la police au delà nous comprenons
ces difficultés nous la soutenons mais
ce que nous cherchons à savoir sur ces
événements c'est pourquoi 400 millions
de téléspectateurs ce soir là ont vu un
stade de france à l'occasion d'un
événement sportif majeur se retrouver
dans une telle situation c'est pour nous
quelque chose d'incompréhensible et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on veut
simplement comprendre les choses
avaient pris dans la forme
président du fai à donner les grandes
orientations des questions je ne serai
pas plus long parce que je pense que
pour le rendre notre dialogue le plus
interactive possible le mieux est de
vous écouter pendant quelques minutes
dans un propos liminaire d'une dizaine
de minutes et puis après que nous
échangions se forme de
questions-réponses j'aurai quelques
questions
en tout début mais je le plus simple je
pense et de vous laisser la parole pour
que effectivement donné déjà quelques
éléments liminaire sur des deux grandes
séries de questions cac a présenté le
président de buffet moi j'insiste aussi
comme il l'a fait ce que notre rôle est
éteinte dans le cadre de notre exercice
de contrôle est un rôle de compréhension
de 2,2 ce qui s'est passé a à la fois
parce que nous nous le devons à ceux qui
en ont été victimes
mais aussi parce que nous sommes en
préparation de grands événements
sportifs et que nous devons tirer tous
les enseignements de cette finale de la
champions league en vue de la
préparation de la coupe du monde et des
jeux olympiques c'est l'état d'esprit
dans lequel nous sommes ici pour ça que
nous sommes très désireux d'avoir cet
échange avec vous et d'avoir les
réponses à un certain nombre de
questions qui se posent encore sur cet
événement sportif de la finale du double
si je préfère je vous laisse la parole
merci messieurs les présidents mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je vous
remercie tout d'abord de votre
invitation elle permettra je l'espère de
clarifier les choses qui ne le serait
pas je voudrais toutefois avant toute
chose vous dire qu'en tant que préfet de
police je suis le seul responsable
opérationnel de l'ordre et de la
sécurité publique sur l'agglomération
parisienne et c'est à dire
l'agglomération parisienne c'est paris
et les trois départements de la petite
couronne je ne suis d'ailleurs pas le
préfet de police de paris je suis le
préfet de police tout court on puisqu'en
l'occurrence le sujet concerne la seine
saint denis je vais être très clair là
dessus les préfets de départements de la
petite couronne n'ont aucune compétence
en matière
d'ordre et de sécurité publique les
fonctionnaires de police et les
militaires de gendarmerie qui
interviennent le font donc sous mon
autorité directe ou sous celle que je
donne par délégation indique aux
fonctionnaires qui toi du corps
préfectoral ou de la police
j'assume donc en totalité la
responsabilité de la gestion policière
de la journée du samedi 28 mai et je le
répète encore une fois j'en suis devant
vous mais également devant le pays le
seul comptable opérationnel
ceux qui ont agi l'ont fait sous mon
commandement je les dis et je veux
d'abord laissez lui
policiers ou gendarmes ils ont fait
preuve d'une énergie et d'une volonté ce
soir là comme à l'accoutumée que je
voudrais ici souligné sans eux un drame
aurait pu se produire
je leur fait donc part publiquement
comme je lé fais plus indirectement de
ma reconnaissance pour leurs actions et
de ma fierté de les avoir sous mes
ordres ils ne sont pas pour moi des
troupiers expression d'un siècle passé
que l'on associe plutôt mot comique même
si elle ne me fait pas rire mais des
collègues ou des camarades d'une grande
valeur professionnelle et morale
n'éludant pas mes responsabilités je
regarde ou du moins j'essaye de regarder
avec la plus grande lucidité
possible ce qui s'est passé autour du
stade de france ce soir là
c'est à l'évidence un échec car des
personnes ont été bousculés ou agresser
alors que nous leur devions la sécurité
c'est un échec aussi car l'image du pays
vous l'avez souligné messieurs les
présidents a été ébranlée
mais je dois insister au delà de cet
échec sur le fait que face à une crise
d'ampleur dans un contexte dégradé est
difficile nous avons fait en sorte que
le match se tiennent et surtout surtout
qu'il n'y ait aucun blessé grave est qu
aucun mort
qui plus est sur paris intra muros
sur la circulation des supporters que
sur la fan zone ou bien hors de paris
sur les aéroports eux même temps de
roissy et d'orly il n'y a eu aucun
incident significatif
je vous disait avoir conscience que
l'image de la france a été atteinte
c'est une blessure pour moi car l'amour
de la patrie et l'honneur du drapeau
compte plus que tout à nos hôtes
étrangers qu'ils soient espagnols ou
anglais qui ce soir là n'ont pas tous
trouvé les conditions sur d'un accueil
ainsi qu'à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
français je veux dire également mes
regrets sincères comme le ministre de
l'intérieur l'a demandé des prêts
plaintes seront disponibles en ligne et
des fonctionnaires de la préfecture de
police sont présents à liverpool et à
madrid pour les aider si besoin est à
les remplir
j'encourage donc l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens mais également les
ressortissants anglais espagnol a porté
plainte c'est extrêmement important pour
que nous puissions recoupent pour
retrouver et poursuivre leurs agresseurs
mais également à porter plainte si
jamais ils ont acheté des faux billets
c'est très important que nous ayons
également une vision
claire des choses en la matière et je
leur promets donc à tout ce que nous
ferons tout pour retrouver les coupables
et les présenter à la justice
je ne reviendrai pas longuement sur les
causes de ce qui s'est passé ce soir là
les ministres ayant dans leur audition
déjà larges sommes largement détaillé
l'analyse que l'on peut en faire je veux
toutefois insisté sur deux décisions que
j'ai eu à prendre et sur les
conséquences qu'elles ont eues
d'abord celle de la levée du barrage du
prêt filtrage 10 de l'avenue wilson
vers 19h45
notre rôle sur les barrages et d'assurer
une protection anti terroriste avec des
véhicules faisant fonction d'ans tibet
libre reprendre notre terminologie
il est avec la présence d'effectifs muni
de ce qu'on appelle des armes longues
c'est à dire destiné à parer une attaque
terroriste
vous vous souvenez tous que le stade de
france a été l'objet d'une attaque
terroriste et que ce ne sont pas des
gesticulations mais une absolue
nécessité face à une menace qui est
toujours existante les forces de
sécurité intérieure sous ce vocable je
vise bien évidemment temps les policiers
que les gendarmes que j'avais sur mon
autorité n'était donc pas chargée de la
vérification des billets pas plus que la
préfecture de police n'était
l'organisateur de l'événement la des
prérogatives de vérification des billets
était de la responsabilité de
l'organisateur et d'ailleurs si notre
dispositif lors des événements sportifs
à cet endroit toujours prévu des prêts
filtrage c'est à dire les contrôles de
personnes cela ne faisait que la
deuxième fois depuis 2013 je crois que
des contrôles de billets étaient
réalisés à ce niveau je parle toujours
du prêt barrages il s'est avéré avec
l'arrivée tardive est plutôt massive
d'ailleurs de supporters du peut-être
aux difficultés de transport que ce
contrôle c'est emboliser en effet les
personnes rejetées pour l'absence de
ville de validité de leurs titres soit
essayer de passer à tout prix soit
nous pouvons y arriver quand car elle ne
pouvait plus reculer en raison du nombre
toujours plus grand de personnes
leur succédant est en quelque sorte
étant derrière elle et les empêchant de
reculer nous avons aidé les personnes
chargées du contrôle à maintenir ce
barrage mais un moment toutes les
indications qui me remontait ont fait
craindre un grain un drame par
écrasement et vous voyez lien très
précisément ce que j'évoque quand je
parle de drams par écrasement et une
bousculade de plusieurs milliers de gens
nous constatons en effet au delà de
cette file des présences de plus en plus
importante de personnes dont le plus
grand nombre semblaient être des
supporters
à noter que si la préfecture de police
disposait d'informations précises sur le
nombre et les trajets de supporters
venant de madrid venant d'espagne de la
part de l'uefa cela n'a pas été le cas
pour les supporters de liverpool
incités par leur club à venir
massivement à paris même dépourvu de
tickets sans que nous n'ayons des
indications précises sur une
organisation au niveau du club de ce
déplacement et donc ça a été une série
de déplacements individuels voir
collectif mais non organisés comme les
tel déplacement des supporters
de madrid les premiers veulent un
élément venant des opérateurs de
transport confirme s est arrivé à
l'origine du chiffre de 30 à 40 mille
personnes situées aux alentours du stade
c'est moi qui ai donné ce chiffre au
ministre et là aussi je l'assumé
totalement
on peut avoir une discussion sur
l'exactitude du chiffre qui en fait dans
les tableaux qui ont été présentées par
le ministre quand j'ai dit 30 à 40000
ses 34 milles sur la base des
indications qui nous était donné ce soir
là par les opérateurs de transport et du
constat que nous pouvions faire
donc on peut tout à fait avoir cette
discussion autour de ce chiffre
j'observe d'ailleurs que des enquêtes de
prince ont été faites qui aboutissent à
un chiffre légèrement inférieur d'à peu
près 24 milles mais je vais vous dire au
plan opérationnel
l'ampleur du chiffre au delà de
plusieurs milliers de personnes en
dehors en périphérie pardon des barrages
n'était pas essentielle et ne l'est
toujours pas le risque qu'une masse
supplémentaire de personnes
s'ajoutant aux 10 à 15000 déjà présent
sur 7 que wilson que je vais dénommé
ainsi était en soi une
menace extrême et pouvaient s'ajouter à
la difficulté déjà grave et accroît
c'est en quelque sorte le risque de
pertes de vie et de blessures graves je
veux vraiment souligner cet élément car
il a été le fil rouge de mon attitude de
notre attitude tout au long de la soirée
sauver des vies sauvées des personnes
alors oui j'ai donné l'ordre de lâcher
une barrages et de laisser passer la
foule sans s'y opposer par des
manoeuvres de police une nouvelle fois
publiquement devant vous j'assume cet
ordre ce faisant je laissais l'accès
libre à l'espace autour du stade alors
que dans toutes les compétitions
précédentes ils étaient filtrées et donc
inaccessible à des personnes aux
intentions douteuses
c'est ce qui s'est passé à mon avis pour
trois ou quatre cents individus
peut-être légèrement plus que l'on peut
ainsi qualifié et qui se sont livrés à
des vols et à des dégradations
d'autres se tenant en périphérie des
gars là dispositif ne présentant plus
l'étanchéité suffisante et la capacité
dissuasive
nécessaires pour empêcher ces vols le
vent ce barrage nous avons levé
progressivement les autres barrages
puisque le public arrivait dans le dos
des autres barrages dans le barrage nord
que les barrages est et donc venant du
sud et accédant à ce parvis où ce maul
peu importe la dénomination du stade
donc la foule y pénètrent et largement
indépendamment de tout contrôle donc il
fallait forcément lever les barrages qui
ne servait plus à rien bien évidemment
les supporters anglais et d'autres se
sont concentrés sur les portes d'accès
au stade par lesquels ils devaient
passer et donc des incidents se sont
produits sur les portes y z et à sa a
été largement documenté mêmes causes ont
produit les mêmes effets vu de notre
vision police car je ne sais pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé sur les
contrôles du billet et ses portes ont
menacé de lâcher et quand même été
parfois franchies de façon à sauter par
dessus les portillons voir par dessus
les grillages j'ai donc pris une seconde
décision celle de replier une grande
partie du dispositif à l'intérieur du
stade pour éviter son envahissement par
des milliers de personnes dont je ne
savais pas si elle était autorisée ou
nous à y rentrer si ces milliers de
personnes y étaient rentrés dans ce
stade sans en avoir la le billet la
billetterie nécessaire il n'y aurait pas
eu de match tout simplement et donc ce
que nous avons fait c'est permettent le
match le match moi ce qui m'intéresse de
côté d'une usine dans une vision
policière c'est bien sûr qu'il se tienne
au plan sportif mais surtout qu'on ne se
retrouve pas avec soixante dix mille
personnes extrêmement mécontente et qui
aurait pu elle même provoqué à ce moment
là des mouvements de foule donc il est
absolument nécessaire quand un stade est
plein que le match se joue un pour
éviter des évacuations et de nouvelle
bousculade c'est-à-dire à lui des ordres
ajouter du désordre
pour diminuer la pression de la foule
sur les grilles et l'éternité il fallait
faire reculer les gens
puisque la pression c'est toujours le
même sujet la pression la pression la
pression nous avons nous demandé aux
gens de reculer et force est de
constater qu'il ne s'est rien passé
alors nous avons utilisé vous l'avez
site et messieurs les présidents et je
l'assumé également complètement des gaz
lacrymogènes seul moyen à notre
connaissance policière pour faire
reculer une foule sauf à la charge et je
le répète ce que vient de dire seul
moyen au plan policier pour faire
reculer une foule sauf à la charge et je
pense que ça aurait été une erreur grave
de charger les gens
cela a fonctionné c'est à dire
l'utilisation des gaz lacrymogènes j'ai
bien conscience qu'en se faisant ont été
gazés des personnes de bonne foi il y en
a des personnes de bonne foi est prise
dans cette foule et parfois même des
familles j'en suis totalement désolé au
nom de la préfecture de police et je le
redis il n'y avait malheureusement pas
d'autres moyens cette action de police
impérative en interrogeant rien la
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre semblant
à fait dans ce que j'ai vu des
commentaires de presse
à voir en la matière une confusion le
débat porte le débat sur la doctrine
portes de sa mort pardon porte sur le
fait de savoir dans une manifestation à
risque si les forces de sécurité
intérieure se tiennent à distance ou si
elle son contact tout le débat sur le
schéma national du maintien de l'ordre
porté sur cet élément là
depuis que je suis en poste les choses
sont parfaitement claires je crois là
dessus je m'en suis exprimé publiquement
je préconise dans le cas où le risque de
trouble à l'ordre public et fort d'être
en contact je me souviens des images du
1er mai 2018 ou lorsqu un espace est
laissée aux casseurs ils n'hésitent pas
à l'occuper à l'utiliser et à provoquer
des destructions pour je porte
effectivement cette nécessité de contact
je les dis je les recommandés dans le
schéma national maintien de l'ordre qui
a été ainsi arrêté par le ministre mais
en espèces
ce n'était pas le problème puisque nous
étions d'ores et déjà au contact c'est
mm toute la difficulté c'est d'être
beaucoup trop au contact avec une foule
nous pressent donc c'est pas un débat
doctrine sur le maintien de l'ordre
c'est tout simplement un problème de
manoeuvre dans le maintien de l'ordre
est donc le sujet de la doctrine me
paraît ne pas avoir de rapport avec les
interrogations qui sont celles qui se
pose est est une seule encore préval est
absolument c'était celle de sauver des
vies une fois le match commencé nous
avons évacué ce que moi j'appelle le
parvis c'est-à-dire l'alentour du stade
qui était protégé par notre système de
barrages en chassant les gens qui
étaient et notamment me semble-t-il les
3 400 indésirables que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure en utilisant effectivement l'un
des moyens intermédiaires et de diverses
natures et notamment des grenades
lacrymogènes mais n'étaient pas
concernés par cette évacuation les
spectateurs qui entre temps avait pu
rentrer puisque cette évacuation s'est
produit une fois le match commencé mais
à l'évidence et c'est qu'ils aient le
sentiment que j'ai le groupe de ses
indésirables je les qualifie comme tel
on peut trouver d'autres noms à ce que
vous le souhaitez ne s'est pas dispersée
mais est resté aux alentours dans la
périphérie du stade je confirme donc que
les causes de la situation des tripes
sont le nombre très élevé de bière
rejetée par les contrôles et
vraisemblablement pour la plupart fou
sauf si bien sûr les organisateurs nous
indiquait une défaillance dont j'ai pas
connaissance de leur système de contrôle
tant sur leur stylo chimiques sur les
barrages que dans les dispositifs de
tourniquets à l'entrée du stade je
reconnais donc quand le vent le
périmètre sécurisé des troubles et des
délits ont pu se réaliser aux abords du
stade puisque mon dispositif qui avait
été opérant sur tous les précédents
matches ne l'était plus pour la raison
indiqué mais je revendique et je me
permets d'insister peut-être un peu
lourdement trouverez-vous en la matière
sur le fait que les décisions prises
étaient les seuls qui pouvaient garantir
l'intégrité physique des personnes et la
tenue du match
voilà monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ce que je peux
vous dire en préalable
merci monsieur le préfet pour ses
premiers éléments d'information j'ai
quelques questions à vous poser puis
après bien sûr chacun d'eux des
sénatrices et des sénateurs eux pourront
également intervenir vous nous avez
décrit les faits le jour du match
comment ils se sont déroulés moi je
voudrais revenir un peu en amont sur la
préparation de l'événement les deux
ministres quand nous les avons su la
semaine dernière nous ont fait état d'un
certain nombre de réunions préparatoires
ce qui n'est pas surprenant évidemment
en indiquant que certaines réunions
était placée sous l autorité du dijon et
d'autres sous votre présidence je crois
que ces termes utilisés par le ministre
de l'intérieur
confirmé hier c'était sous votre
présidence et à travers ça en votre
présence
moi je voudrais savoir comment était
anticipé notamment lors des dernières
réunions je pense à celle du 25 et 27
mai sert juste avant
avant la finale et alors même que deux
éléments nouveaux étaient portés à
connaissance des deux éléments nouveaux
au porter à connaissance était bien sûr
la grève du rer b avec l'impact que cela
peut avoir
sur les flux de voyageurs à la sortie de
des deux gares et l'organisation des
points de filtrage et puis aussi la note
de la division de lutte contre le
hooliganisme qu'ils faisaient clairement
état d'une présence massive de
supporters de liverpool en plus de ceux
qui avaient des billets
quels ont été les décisions prises
qu'elle était l'évaluation de ces deux
risques lors des réunions préparatoires
et singulièrement des deux dernières
années 25 et du 27 mai à la fois sur le
fait qu'ils aient une grève du rer b
avec l'impact encore une fois que ça
peut avoir sur l'organisation des flux
et puis cette identification d'un nombre
important de supporter des verts poule
sans billet
vous avez raison de le rappeler monsieur
le président
la coordination de la préparation
a relevé d'ailleurs comme tous les
grands événements sportifs de la
responsabilité du délégué
interministériel et nous avons nous
préfecture de police participez à
l'ensemble des réunions préparatoires 1
qui ont eu lieu en la matière dans
lesquelles ont été évoqués tous ces
sujets et notamment les sujets
ddd des risques de grève nous avons eu
par ailleurs un certain nombre de
réunions dans d'autres formats avec
différents acteurs sur des points
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus précis
là les éléments sur le nombre de
supporters susceptibles de venir sans
préciser dans la note des lainages qui
donne d'ailleurs un chiffre de 50 mille
assez important en fait et donc ce qui a
été prévu par la ddjs et qui avaient mon
complète accord était le dispositif de
fan zone donc dimensionné pour l'un à 44
milles sur le cours de vincennes avec
l'aide de la mairie de paris que je
tiens à remercier
ainsi que celui de 6000 personnes au
niveau du parle de la légion d'honneur
avec l'aide de la ville de saint denis
que je tiens également à a remercié donc
nous savions que notre dispositif de fan
zone
negreneys pas la totalité les personnes
sans billet puisque d'un côté je vous
parle de 50 de l'autre deux côtés de
2,44 à différents soit 106 on a pensé
que 6000 serait dans différents cafés en
un endroit où on pouvait voir le match
c'est d'ailleurs ce les premières
observations de la journée le montrer ce
que des supporters de liverpool étaient
répartis un peu partout dans paris et
encore une fois leur attitude très
pacifique a permis qui mouillait que
très très peu d'incidents même si un
certain nombre était quand même assez
alcoolisées
et donc
sur l'anticipation pour répondre
précisément à votre question de la grève
les expériences que nous avions eus
précédemment nous montrer que même en
cas d'arrivée massive de supporters
le dispositif d'accès des je vais
l'appeler comme ça c'est à dire les
supporters sortant du rer d et à
l'envers cette fameuse rompu wilson dans
le passé on avait été confrontée à des
arrivées assez significative de 2 de
fans de spa de spectateurs en un seul
bloc est certes l'endroit est très
étroit mais la fluidité avait été
assurée alors c'est vrai qu'il y avait
pas de contrôle de billet dans les
exemples que je donne et donc nous
sommes partis du principe que nous nous
mettrions en place je suis parti du
principe que nous ne mettrions en place
des barrages pour dévier les gens
sortant du d anvers l'accès des
supporters sortant dubé qui permettait
par une avenue plus large d'accéder au
stade que si nous étions dans la
situation d'une embolie du dispositif et
c'est vrai que nous ne l'avons fait je
crois qu à
19h15 cette déviation des gens sortant
du dea pour les renvoyer sur la voie
d'accés dubé encore une fois j'utilise
cette terminologie impossible faire
comprendre
que ce dans ces cas cet horaire là
sans doute était-ce trop tardif nous
aurions dû le faire un petit peu avant
car nous avons constaté que le nombre de
gens qui s'agglomèrent père est sur la
rampe wilson était beaucoup beaucoup
trop important 1 19h15 j'ai dit madame
la sénatrice
c'est vrai nous aurions pu sans doute
gagner un quart d'heure dans une
manoeuvre pour alléger la pression par
rapport à cette arrivée mais allez c'est
pas tellement ce qui me souciais ce qui
me souciais c'est que je dévie nous
avions dévier le flux mais nous avions
quand même 10 à 15000 personnes
entassées dans cette robe enfin vous
connaissez les lieux un c'est pas
tellement la rampe c'est que la route
passe effectivement sous l'a86 mais
c'est surtout surtout qu'il y a le
tunnel sous l'un qui est un tout petit
tunnel 1 qui permet de passer sous
l'autoroute qu'elle quitta tunnel
facteurs de risque mais ainsi et le
stade de france ainsi il a été construit
ainsi les accès ont été constitués
police peut beaucoup de choses dans ce
pays mais pas pousser les murs
et donc je n'avais pas de raison de
penser qu'un afflux de personnes même
dans cette situation là même en cas de
grève aboutirait à cette situation
la présence de supporters sans billet
nous ne l'avions pas nous de notre côté
envisagé avec des faux billets
c'est à dire que
les choses n'avaient pas hésité
envisager de cette façon là et j'essaye
de répondre le plus sincèrement possible
à votre situation face à ce qui se
passait et surtout je le répète je les
dis dans mon interview dans mon
intervention préliminaire
à la connaissance que nous avions qu'au
delà des flux qui arrivait il y avait la
présence de supporters dans la
périphérie de nos barrages vrai que tous
les chiffres qui nous était donnée par
les opérateurs montrer qu'il arrivait
plus de gens que la capacité de
contenance du stade et donc nous avions
en face de nous un nombre extrêmement
important de gens susceptibles de venir
faire pression sur les barrages
merci c'est ce point est important parce
que nous avons besoin de comprendre
aussi comment se pèse la coordination
entre les différents acteurs on sait
qu'il ya l'organisateur les l'uefa avec
la fédération française de football la
préfecture de police sous votre autorité
et notamment sur le plan de la gestion
des flux qui décide de quoi à quel
moment c'est vrai que quand on analyse
les faits c'est toujours plus facile de
des anisés après bien entendu mais qu'on
voit qu'il ya trois points de filtrage à
la sortie du rer b ont corrigerait si je
me trompe et huit ou neuf je le dis de
mémoire à la sortie du rer d alors même
que les flux de voyageurs vont être
inversée par la grève du rer on
s'interroge pour savoir si
l'organisation d'aidé points de filtrage
a été revue à l'occasion de l'annoncé du
rer b où nous dit si je
parce que je me permets d'insister sur
la question mais qui n'a pas fait
l'objet d'une réelle interrogation en
tout cas au moment où il ya eu cette
annonce de grève
je vais peut-être à ce moment-là revenir
sur l'achitecture de l'organisation du
dispositif
je nous n'avions pas la charge des
points de filtrage donc je ne peux pas
vous répondre sur les points de filtrage
encore une fois nous n'étions pas sur
les points de filtrage nous étions dans
un dispositif anti terroriste en amont
des points de filtrage et en renfort des
personnels du stade derrière au moment
des bousculades c'est à dire nous
arrivons en arrière du dispositif pour
secondes et les personnels lorsque ça
commence à bousculer mais dans tout le
début de l'opération nous sommes devant
parce que notre problème c'est un acte
terroriste qui viendrait de l'extérieur
en amont du premier filtrage donc je ne
peux pas vous dire si un point de vue de
l'organisation du dispositif de contrôle
des billets dès éléments ont été ou non
pris en compte par les organisateurs
vous voyez cet après midi les
organisateurs petit mieux que moi
pourront-ils vous répondre notre
organisation nous par rapport à ça elle
était elle était extrêmement classique
parce que nous ne verrions pas que
l'événement au stade de france donc je
pilotais dans la salle opérationnelle de
la direction de l'ordre public de la pp
l'ensemble du dispositif un
qui centralisait et synthétiser les
informations venant des fans zone car il
y avait toujours en même temps les fans
zone est bien évidemment ce qui se passe
au stade de france tout seul de france
il y à un pc sécurité dans lequel il y à
la police les forces de gendarmerie qui
qui sont mis à ma disposition et bien
sûr les organisateurs du stade sous
poste de commandement je l'avait confié
à mon directeur de cabinet ainsi seconde
et par l'inspecteur général marsan qui
est ici présents et c'est donc dans
cette itération cette remontée du pc de
terrain que me remonter les informations
que je vous ai signalé un instant et
donc le contact avec les organisateurs
se faisait au travers de ce pc dans
lequel sont les responsables du stade de
france
donc il ya eu des échanges qui ensuite
ne remontèrent mais au niveau de mon
propre poste de commandement de mon
propre pc je n'avais pas de contact avec
les organisateurs je note d'ailleurs
pour être parfaitement précis puisque je
vois que c'est important je sais pas
19h15 c'est 19h18 enfin ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure je crois que c'est
tentant
notre question poids pour avancer et
puis après je céderai la parole mais mes
collègues
c'est le chiffre bien sûr des 30 à 40000
spectateurs supplémentaires qui
n'avaient pas de billets ou qui avait
des faux billets et mais en tout cas
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas rentrer dans le
stade vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
dans votre propre aux luminaires vous
savez que ce chiffre ces débats et pose
question je crois vous corrigerez si je
me trompe que vous êtes le premier à
avoir avancé ce chiffre en tout cas dans
la note que nous a transmis le le
ministre de l'intérieur note que vous
avez rédigé en date du 29 c'est à dire
le lendemain de duke du match vous
précisez vous même avec une prudence
toutefois que ce sont sans doute entre
30000 à 40000 personnes qui étaient au
delà des 80 milles administrés dans le
stade ma question est toute simple
d'où vient ce chiffre au moment où vous
l'annoncer enfin vous l'écrivez hominis
quelles sont les informations à votre
disposition pour avancer un chiffre dont
on sait qu'il va faire débat qui fait
toujours débat quels sont votre source
au moment où vous quelles sont vos
sources pardon au moment où les annonces
j'ai bien vu que je suis faisait débat
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris la
précaution de vous dire que j'en suis le
seul responsable d'ailleurs c'est moi
qui l'ait écrit donc je vous donne le
chiffre tel que nous l'avions au moment
des événements et remontaient bien
évidemment des constats des opérateurs
de transport par mois qui compte le
nombre de personnes dans l'est dans les
wagons mais également des
dispositifs que nous avions puisque je
suis responsable de la police des
transports donc il ya des équipes qui
sont dans qui était d'ailleurs déployé
dans l'ensemble du dispositif
de transport conduisant au stade de
france tant sur le b que sur dès que sur
les lignes de métro donc cdi précédé ce
sont des effectifs de la police des
transports qui défend qui dépendent de
la direction
de la sécurité publique pour aller plus
vite dans l'expression de la préfecture
de police et donc j'avais à la fois des
chiffres montant des opérateurs mais
également le constat des fonctionnaires
de terrain de d'éléments de volume mais
du constat voilà qui est fait
classiquement qui était de dire ben
voilà par rapport à ce qu'on connaît on
évalue et c'est donc encore une fois le
chiffre n'avait pas une vertu
scientifique mais simplement la
remontée d'une information mais qu'elles
étaient absolument capital c'est qu'il y
avait largement plus de personnes que la
contenance du stade et que si ces
personnes avec toute cette pression sur
les barrages puis ensuite sur les portes
nous allions à d'extrêmes difficultés
donc peut-être me suis-je trompé dans le
chiffre de 30 à 40 milles que j'ai donné
au ministre d'ailleurs nous allons
essayer de le reconstituer une ministre
vous à fourmies d'ailleurs je crois dans
un powerpoint des éléments de calcul qui
ont été reconstitués ensuite avec les
opérateurs voilà mais
jamais je n'ai prétendu que ce chiffre
était à à quelques milliers parfaitement
juste mais il me paraît totalement
refléter ce qu'était la situation est le
fait qu'il y avait autour des supporters
encore une fois il n'a jamais été dit
que la présence de ces trente à quarante
mille personnes étaient au strict abords
du stade je crois avoir même dit le
contraire ce que j'ai lu ça dans les
journaux des gens de bonne foi dix ans
mais on n'a pas de compte et 30000 à
40000 personnes sur le parvis du stade
sur le môle du stade ou devant les
portes du stade voilà je vais le dire
comme ça mais nous non plus on n'a
jamais compté trente et quarante et une
personnes devant les portes du stade les
30 à 40 milles on les voit on les
subodorait sur la périphérie de nos
barrages c'est à dire sur les arrivées
subodorait au regard des éléments
fournis par les abbés raté est-ce que ça
qui est important mais c'est le préfet
ce que je m'arrêterai là je parle au
président du ps que quinze jours
quasiment après l'événement on peut
avoir aujourd'hui des chiffres plus
précis sur ce qu'était aux abords des
points de filtration je vous ai donné
tout ce que nous avions et qui figure
dans le powerpoint que vous a présenté
le ministre après je pense que les
opérateurs mieux que moi pourrons vous
donner peut-être des choses plus précise
mais nous leur avons demandé encore une
fois ces chiffres là ne sortent pas
contrairement à ce que j'entends
de
d'une idée qui me serait passé par la
tête quand une fois c'est des éléments
mais je voudrais revenir là dessus parce
que j'ai bien compris que c'était un
sujet comme on dit politique moi je le
vois d'une façon opérationnelle
une façon opérationnelle
qu'il y autour quarante mille trente
mille ou 20000 personnes ça ne changeait
rien au fait qu'il y avait des dizaines
de milliers de personnes susceptibles de
rentrer dans le dispositif et c'était
sale information absolument essentiel
après les comptes et à 5000 près n'avait
en termes opérationnels pas grande
importance
j'ai passé je rebondis sur ce que vous
venez de dire
d'abord il nous surprend que les
chiffres annoncés ne sont ne soit pas
corroboré aujourd'hui par des images de
vidéosurveillance de vidéoprotection on
imagine bien être le stade est lui-même
parfaitement équipés de cela et qui a
donc incontestablement des éléments qui
nous permettraient de visualiser les
choses peut-être même de les quantifier
et ainsi de pouvoir corroborer ou non
les chiffres annoncés moi ma question
elle porte sur cette note de l'adn à la
hd est née large pardon du 25 mètres
2022 c'est notre que nous avons qui nous
a été remise très clairement dans un
premier temps le ministre nous dit ne
l'avoir jamais vu en début d'audition
est en cours d'audition inuits
finalement il en a eu connaissance où
est la vérité
monsieur le président la vérité très
simple d'ailleurs le mime d'abord le
ministre ne vous a jamais dit qu'il me
l'avait jamais vu il vous indique que le
préfet de police ne l'avait jamais eu
sur la base de ce que je lui avais
indiqué
quelques finalement j'en avais bien moi
je titre personnel je ne l'avais jamais
vue et donc le ministre a répété ce que
je lui dis et j'ai ensuite corrigé en
séance en disant effectivement il existe
à la préfecture de police cette note
mais très franchement moi je ne l'avais
pas le plus pour une raison qui tient
nos procédures c'est à dire que nous
avons une direction du renseignement qui
reprend l'ensemble des éléments qui lui
sont fournis et qu'elle synthétise dans
des notes propre à la direction du
renseignement donc les éléments de la
note de l'adn h elle était parfaitement
connue de nous puisqu'elle figurait dans
la note de la drpp mais la note en
elle-même avec le timbre des lainages
j'ai dit la vérité monsieur le président
car je la dis toujours je ne l'avais
jamais vu mais le ministre nous a jamais
dit qu'il ne l'avait pas vu j'ai écouté
son audition il nous a dit que le préfet
de police ne l'avait pas eu et ensuite
parce que peut-être je suis considéré
que je mettais mal exprimée en lui
disant ça je fume je
lui ai envoyé un petit sms en lui disant
me suis je les ai eues mais ce que j'ai
dit c'est que moi préfet de police je ne
l'avais pas vu et je le redis d'ailleurs
mais d'ailleurs ça n'a pas grande
importance l'essentiel était que
l'information soit fournie par les
services de renseignement et ses
éléments fournis étaient dans les notes
de la direction du renseignement de la
préfecture de police donc si vous voulez
on peut épiloguer sur savoir si c'est
sous le mont thabor et cetera peu
importe jaser effectivement ces niveaux
d'information
bien mais je redis on verra ce que dit
la déclaration de nice dans tous les cas
ils s'étaient positionnés en disant
qu'ils n'avaient pas eu connaissance de
cette note après que ce soit vous je
sois lui personnellement tous les cas il
n'avait pas cette information
dit il ensuite pour corriger
effectivement sans doute sur votre
intervention mais moi je ne partage pas
tout à fait votre point de vue sur le
fait que cet été malgré tout assez
intéressante en terme de chiffres et de
quantum et de risque annoncé et je
trouve mes soutiens avis strictement
personnelles qu'elle conditionne quand
même les circonstances de cet événement
et en tous les cas permettent
pouvait permettre peut être de voir les
choses un peu différemment
sur le président vous me permettez de
vous interrompre
pour être parfaitement clair sur ce que
je viens de vous dire ces éléments je
les avais vous me parlez de la forme moi
je vous parle du fond ces éléments sur
le fond ont été portés à la connaissance
par la direction du renseignement de la
préfecture de police qui se documente de
toute une série de sources potentielles
de la dlna donc je vous dis que j'avais
ces éléments et est ce qu'ils ont fait
l'objet de discussions avec les
organisateurs au moment des réunions
préparatoires
c'est un élément quand même important
dont on a vu les conséquences le jour du
match est-ce que lors des réunions du 25
et 27 mai cette note a fait l'objet
d'une discussion ayez les risques bien
sûr que ça comportait avons fait l'objet
d'une discussion avec les organisateurs
pas à ma connaissance la note en elle
même pas à ma connaissance les
informations sur le nombre de personnes
susceptibles de venir oui la note en
elle-même je ne crois pas tu préfet de
questions supplémentaires avant de la
parole à monsieur monsieur de savin et à
d'autres qui demanderont la parole
naturellement une question presque naïve
la gare de monthey et elle présente ce
soir là au stade de france alors que par
exemple elle est présente régulièrement
dans tous les matches et notamment le
dernier l'équipe de france au stade
parce que nous connaissons les effets
sécurisant de sa présence et puis la
troisième chose n'a évoqué tout à
l'heure le nombre de 400 peut-être 500
personnes que je qualifierais volontiers
probablement de deux délinquants ou de
gens susceptibles de commettre des
infractions
quelle a été la réponse pénale
le nombre d'arrestations
les poursuites engagées quels ont été
les instructions données pour lutter
contre ceux qui ont fait les poches des
uns et des autres puisqu'il est avéré
aujourd'hui que ces faits ont bien eu
lieu
alors sur la présence de fonctionnaires
à cheval oui il y avait des
fonctionnaires à cheval il y avait une
dizaine de fonctionnaires à cheval en la
matière comme nous déployons
classiquement ni plus ni moins
d'ailleurs nous laisse systématiquement
ils sont présents sur l'ensemble des
matchs sur la réponse pénale bombe je
pense qu'il est mieux que moi les
magistrats pourront vous répondre nous
avons fait un certain nombre
d'interpellations elles ont été
communiqués par le ministre en stricte
aux abords du stade que plus loin dans
la périphérie mais votre question
monsieur le président me permets de 2,2
de répondre peut-être à une
interrogation que j'ai vu poindre dans
le débat public c'est j'ai vu poser la
question mais pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
interpeller de supporters qui avaient de
faux billets parce qu'effectivement nous
n'avons pas fait un nous nous sommes
concentrés encore une fois sur ce qui me
semblait essentiel et sur les délits que
nous constations et c'est vrai que j'ai
choisi de ne pas interpellé des gens qui
n'avaient ne passait pas très
franchement au moment où se passerait
les choses pouvions pas savoir s'il ya
une infraction ou un délit c'était très
difficile après avoir non mais je le dis
monsieur le président parce que j'ai vu
cette critique en disant mais
effectivement vous n'avez pas et nous
n'avons interpellé personne en la
matière puisque aucun élément en la
matière sur le plan pénal ne permettait
de le faire
merci qu'on va transmettre la parole à
nos collègues en vous demandant d'être
rapide dans vos questions pour que les
champs choix le le plus direct possible
michel savin pointe première c'est sûr
merci messieurs les présidents monsieur
le préfet mais à messieurs je vais
essayer d'être très rapide en est
question vous évoquiez monsieur le
préfet les milliers de spectateurs avec
billets falsifiés ou sans oublier
le nombre de trente à quarante mille
personnes
moi je voudrais revenir sur la photo qui
a été publiée par tf1 qui à 20h58 la
question est simple où se trouve à 20h58
c'est à dire deux minutes avant le début
du match et 30 à 40000 personnes sans
billet ou faux billets
c'est pas qu'un problème politique
monsieur le préfet parce que le monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur à qui nous
avons posé cette question nous a
réveillés qui nous a répondu que cette
présence de 30 à 40 mille spectateurs en
dehors du stade à 21h serait la seule la
principale cause du report du match or
sur les images nous n'avons pas 30 à
40000 spectateurs dans quelle était la
réponse à apporter à cette question à
sachant qu'à 21h 10000 supporters
anglais n'était toujours pas rentré dans
le stade donc il faut c'est ne sais pas
c'est pas anodin à cette question
c'est une vraie question est ce que
monsieur le ministre qui met en avant
cette présence pour expliquer le report
du match se trompe ou est ce que il ya
d'autres raisons d'autres questions
l'uefa la fédération française de foot
et vote de 1800 faux biscan aux
tourniquets d'entrée du stade alors même
si j'ai bien entendu vous pouvez pas
nous amener siméo - pouvez-vous nous
confirmer comme l'affirment le ministre
de l'intérieur contre 57 et 70% des
tickets présenter au plus près filtrage
étaient frauduleux et dernière question
les débordements et les actes de
délinquance et d'agressions qui se sont
déroulés autour du stade due à la
présence de milliers de supporters de
liverpool qui n'avaient pas de billets
ou qu'ils avaient les faux billets
monsieur le ministre nous a dit que
c'était cette présence aussi qui avait
amené ses délinquance est ce que c'est
votre avis et je voulais bien avoir
votre position sur ce point là c'est le
préfet qui y ont elles se répondre
oui merci monsieur le sénateur j'ai pas
regardé la photo de tf1 mais je crois
avoir tout à leur donner des indications
assez précise les trente à quarante
mille personnes dont j'ai parlé n'était
pas aux abords strict du stade
j'ai expliqué qu'elle était au delà des
barrages au delà au sud des barrages
elle que nous avions les barrages où le
savez étaient pas directement sur
l'entrée du stade mais contrôler l'accès
à ce parvis du stade voilà donc pour
être très précis qu'un évidemment il n'y
avait pas trente à quarante mille
personnes devant les portillons du stade
pour que essayer de vous répondre c'est
évident mais jamais personne n'a dit
sont d'ailleurs je ne sais pas d'où
vient ce débat je vous dis moi les
indications que j'ai les observations
que j'ai fait et les comptes rendus que
j'ai donné au ministre il me semble
d'ailleurs que ce qu'avait expliqué le
ministre était en la matière assez clair
je ne crois pas que il était dit par
quelqu'un que c'était la principale
cause du report du match tel qu'exprimé
me semble-t-il par l'uefa et par la
fédération française la principale cause
de report du match auprès des aéroports
du match était le fait que tous les
spectateurs n'étaient pas encore rentrés
dans le dans le match dans le stade
pardon et qu' il y avait d'ailleurs on
le constate et assez facilement en
regardant les gradins du stade les
supporters anglais n'étaient pas tous là
donc s'ils n'étaient pas tous là c'est
qu'ils étaient à l'extérieur où était-il
en partie devant le stade mais d'autres
étaient ailleurs mais je ne peux pas
répondre à votre question quand vous
dire où il était mais il n'était pas
dans le stade ça c'est une évidence et
je crois que personne ne peut constater
leur absence il sent arriver
progressivement et ce qui a expliqué
cette décision du monde sportif de
reporter
le le début du match
c'était notre grande crainte c'est
qu'effectivement il en a ils arrivent
d'autres supporters qu'ils fassent
encore plus pression sur le dispositif
déjà en difficulté de contrôler au
strict aux abords du stade car le
problème était à ce moment-là de savoir
si suffisamment aurait des billets juste
sur les chiffres qui ont été faits du
des contrôles sur les prés barrage de la
validité des billets parce que je crois
qu'il faut être assez précis il y avait
deux types de contrôle de billet mais
encore une fois mieux que moi les
organisateurs pour en parler tout à
l'heure le pré contrôle en quelque sorte
avec cette affaire de stylos chimiques
dont je suis incapable de vous expliquer
exactement comment ça marche confiance a
consisté à passer inscrire son espèce de
stylos chimiques sur les billets puis
d'en révéler je ne sais quoi qui donnait
la validité au nous et puis ils
contrôleront portillon c'est à dire là
on est comme dans un métro mais son
billet et ça tourne bon ce que les
premières indications qui ont été donnés
on est d'ailleurs été fournies par le
ministre c'est que sur les premiers prix
contrôler il y avait jusqu'à 70 %
d'erreurs
ça a été dit par les organisateurs au
point même que les organisateurs ont
fait et donc nous on l'a constaté portée
des deux autres stylos aux gens qui a
chargé des contrôles en se disant il ya
une défaillance dans les stylos mais ça
je les laisserais tout à leur expliquer
les choses donc s'ils voulaient se
suivent de 70% il tombe pas du ciel il
est fourni par les organisateurs sur
leur premier constat personne n'a jamais
dit que 70% de faux billets mais qui
oserait constat de difficultés sur le
pré filtrage voilà donc je retiens être
parfaitement précis sur les choses et ne
pas laisser
ne pas laisser penser que
quarante mille personnes
mais si le préfet monsieur ça va j'ai
pris des cours et après jérôme durain
parce que nous avons cette demande des
paroles je vais reprendre la déclaration
du ministre de l'intérieur
concernant c'est une délinquance qui
était du fait qu'il y avait des milliers
et des dizaines de milliers de personnes
en plus qui ne rentraient pas dans le
stade et qui était étrangère voilà la
déclaration du ministre de l'intérieur
qui nous que vous nous confirmez pas là
nous dit qu avait quasiment personne à
l'extérieur du stade à 21h à parle de ce
qu'était va rentrer donc monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur rappelez bien
c'était 30 à 48 qui est posé un problème
et qui avait attiré cette délinquance
bien monsieur durand et ensuite ce sera
monsieur assouline mais monsieur du rhin
s'affaiblissent bonjour
occupe c'est finalement c'est la faute
de tout le monde bon on a compris que
c'était essentiellement et fait oublier
mais c'est aussi les supporters et
spécialistes nommé par la lfp qui
explique qu'ils étaient violents alors
qu'on a compris ce n'est pas le cas
c'est la faute de la seine-saint-denis
avec un candidat à la présidentielle qui
explique que c'est un territoire qui
n'est pas vrai public et plus
directement sur les annuaires qui nous
concerne on a certains nombres de
d'agents du ministère de l'intérieur qui
toile quand même des questions de
doctrine vous avez effectué d'une phrase
les questions de doctrine en disant ah
non ça n'est pas le sujet or à
syndicalisme ou dit la préfecture de
police se veut se garder le coeur
médiatique du mas alors le maintien d'or
sur la techique d'avoir avec les
échelons lourd crs gendarmes mobiles et
ensuite avec des moyens plus mobiles et
rapides les bras ou des bikes il ne faut
pas perdre et il termine en disant paris
et seul endroit où la gendarmerie et les
crs ne sont pas invités à la conception
des dispositifs première question la
doctrine de la question c des sels de la
préparation alors on a bien compris qu
avec des notes qui arrivait qu'ils
n'arrivaient pas qui était lui qu'il
n'était pas vu tout ça est assez
compliqué mais il ya quand même aussi
des éléments qui tiennent ou filtrage
aux là 210
produire une contribution qui sera
remise à monsieur cazaux qui a dit quand
même que il eu un certain nombre
d'innovations dans le dispositif de
traits filtrage vous me disiez tout à
l'heure qu'il n'était pas dans votre
compétence de pousser les murs donc ça
je veux bien entendre les murs qui sont
là il existe de vue que le stade de
france existent et quand on met debout
ce sous un pont ça fait évidemment
voulait d'étranglement qui dut en
matière de prêts filtrage des
innovations sur lesquels vous êtes
revenu dans la soirée 19h15 19h18 vous
avez dit qu'ils pourraient expliquer
quand même qu'avec ou sans fouille est
on avait quand même quand même de deux
textes et au stade dernière question en
pin sur l'aide apportée aux supporters
anglais pour des veaux et pince je crois
qu'on va les aider en matière d' actes
délinquants qui courait avoir été les
victimes servir beaucoup plus compliqué
comme tout ce qui concerne les actes
déplacés ou les actions de sommation
liées à d'éventuelles erreurs des forces
de l'ordre et ce sur ce point des
correctifs à apporter
merci alors monsieur le sénateur du
haut-rhin peut-être n'ai-je pas été
claire mais il m'avait semblé l'être je
suis le seul responsable de l'ordre
public et de la sécurité donc j'assume
la totalité des décisions prises et des
conséquences de la situation je sais pas
comment il peut vous le dire mieux que
ça monsieur le sénateur mais j'espère
être parfaitement clair vous me dites
vous renvoyer la balle je ne renvoie la
balle qu'à moi c'est à dire je suis le
seul responsable
j'espère parfaitement clair là dessus
est ce d'ailleurs normal c'est ma
responsabilité
et c'est la responsabilité de la
préfecture de police alors vous
souhaitez savoir comment se préparent
les
les grands événements voir les
manifestations sur le strict aspect
policier alors chante parfois l'art ya
des critiques des uns et des autres vous
évoquez ce syndicaliste que je ne
connais pas
les choses se passent de la façon
suivante quand un dispositif est
organisée il est préparé par la
direction de l'ordre public et il m'est
présenté avec différentes variantes gens
choisis un certain nombre je travaille
sur le dispositif avec les spécialistes
de l'ordre public dans la préfecture de
police nous quantifions les éléments de
2,2
d'effectifs que nous allons employer à
cette occasion et quand on les
quantifiant quantifie à la fois les
effectifs de la préfecture police qui a
ses propres systèmes d'ordre public un
ses propres unités spécialisées en
matière d'ordre public c'est une
spécificité il n'y a qu'une préfecture
de police que sur l'agglomération
parisienne pour des raisons historiques
la préfecture de police existait avant
la police nationale donc il ya un peu de
bien peu d'ancienneté et donc une fois
qu'on a défini ce le quantum de force je
demande des renforts au ministre de
l'intérieur en justifiant du besoin de
renfort par rapport au dispositif que
j'ai choisi
ensuite je présente ce dispositif à
l'ensemble des commandants d'unités
engagés au cours d'un briefing que je
tiens depuis trois ans et demi moi même
à chaque fois avant en fonction de la
date de l'événement moi-même 1 et au
cours duquel les choses leur sont
présentés et au cours desquelles six des
remarques sont en fait elles sont sept
je n'en ai pas entendu au briefing
précédant la mise en place du dispositif
du stade de france
voilà c'est comme ça que se passent les
choses donc il peut bien évidemment il y
avoir des critiques sur le plan sur la
façon dont il est conçu mais encore une
fois en matière d'ordre public comme en
matière de d'événements engageant des
centaines de personnes je parle des
effectifs des forces de sécurité
intérieure croyez moi ça ne se passe
jamais comme prévu est en permanence en
est-on modifier les dispositifs parce
que c'est ainsi que la nature humaine il
y a des différences des choses sur les
supporters anglais a je crois aussi vous
avoir enfin sur les possibilités de
plainte mais encore une fois que nos
amis anglais nos amis espagnols dans le
comportement pour tous ceux qui étaient
de bonne foi n'est pas en cause dans
cette affaire là ce qui est en cause
c'est le comportement des gens qui ont
acheté des faux billets s'ils se sont
fait avoir ce qui est assez
vraisemblable vu le volume 9 juillet et
de grâce qu'il porte plainte qui nous
aide à trouver les responsables de cette
fraude massive c'est la seule façon de
procéder je finis monsieur ça va hein je
ne sais pas comment le dire mais je
crois avoir été très très clairs sur où
était le groupe des 30 à 40000 ce qui se
passait aux strictes aux abords du stade
si je ne les ai pas été je veux bien le
répéter une nouvelle fois j'ai
c'est là
je crois avoir été assez claire le
ministre vous à 10 30 à 40000 personnes
autour du stade moi je vous dis
précisément où étaient ces trente à
quarante mille personnes autour du stade
il était en amont et dispositifs de pré
filtrage même s'il y avait une masse
assez importante de gens qui attendaient
de rentrer puisque je crois qu'il a
manqué jusqu'à 15000 personnes sur les
gradins anglais je crois que c'était à
peu près le chili les premiers
chiffrages qui était fait et que donc
bien évidemment au début du dispositif
vous aviez au moins 15000 personnes aux
abords du stade qui progressivement plus
on se rapprochait du début puis on
approchait dès 21h puis au-delà dès 21h
on finit par rentrer dans le stade donc
je vous parle de la situation une fois
le dispositif la totalité des
spectateurs rentrée mais il ya eu
plusieurs temps c'est à dire que vous
parlez d'une photographie du dispositif
je vous ai donc expliqué qu'elle était
la photographie du dispositif au moment
des prêts barrage quelle était la
photographie du dispositif après la
levée des prêts barrages et quelle était
la photographie du dispositif ensuite
une fois le match commencé le nombre de
personnes hauteur du stade varier en
fonction de ses différentes phases
david assouline et esther benbassa
on prend mule monsieur le préfet
vous vous êtes en charge de gérer
l'ordre mais en même temps de gérer des
situations des fois généré par des
décisions sportives ou politique en
amont
donc moi je veux tout de suite dire une
chose qu'il faudra mettre à notre débat
c'est que quand on voit le dispatch âge
d déplace à 1000 billets pour chaque
club 29000 pour les vip 7000 pour le
grand public 6000 pour des personnes
accréditées par l'uefa
si on continue comme ça il y aura des
désordres partout à chaque grande
manifestation sportive
et je le dis parce que il ya les jo
bientôt
et que si il ya plus de vip et
d'accréditer à ça que ce qu'on peut
donner or au public ou aux supporters et
qu'en plus ces places sont entre 800
euros et des milliers d'euros à ce
moment là
on dit
peuple que c'est pas pour lui et donc ça
générera des masques qui viennent est-ce
qu de l'enceinte et on devra prêt
demandé à la police de gérer ces
décisions qui deviennent je pense
vraiment problématique pour même notre
conception de la démocratie
donc après vous avez à gérer ça parce
que c'était évident qu y aurait donc des
gens qui viendrait d'ailleurs la note
qui vous tombent partout se dit que deux
comme cela a pu être constaté lors de
précédentes finales jouées par le club
de liverpool mais pas que en fait
plusieurs centaines de supporters
anglais tenteront de pénétrer dans le
stade en forçant les tourniquets et
c'est donc on a man who savait au moins
qu'on a plusieurs centaines vous dites
que vous n'avez peut-être plusieurs
milliers mais en amont vous aviez à
gérer ça et donc vous saviez quand vous
avez levé les barrages
bien venir aussi on vous posons une
question comme moi c'est plusieurs
centaines serait aux abords des
tourniquets pour forcer les choses tout
ça était su en fait
c'est le nombre ou il ya peut-être une
différente
ma première question
c'est celle sur la décision de lever le
barrage vous dites vous n'aviez un
dispositif policier comme que
antiterroriste
je suis surpris
qu'en sachant en amour qui a plusieurs
centaines de personnes qui vous forçait
des tourniquets
que la police n'est pas considéré que
c'était aussi à charge les empêcher
d'arriver jusque-là attaque terroriste
j'ai compris mais une question précis
là-dessus
je finis sur une question que j'ai posée
au ministre et là je suis faut pas
prendre les parlementaires pour
des imbéciles j'ai posé une question au
ministre il m'a répondu j'étais très
satisfait de sa réponse il ya un débat
sur la doctrine maintenant dorn alors
préfet vous avez dit vous que vous
n'avez pas d'autre moyen de disperser
pour mettant du gaz qui va toucher des
personnes qui ne souffre au type de rien
on constate dans des manifestations
que par un système de nas etc il ya des
fauteurs de troubles mais que des
citoyens paisibles qui revendique sont à
chaque fois pris dans un tourbillon
organisée par les forces de l'ordre qui
fait qu' ils vont recevoir
une répression
qui ne méritent pas
il a eu la gare de l'est où il ya eu la
même chose j'ai de manger parce que
j'interrogeais la doctrine maintiennent
leur pas idéologique ce conte ou dit de
moi debrief j'ai dit le préfet a dû
faire un brief il ya des télégrammes qui
sont envoyées aux unités sur clark
monsieur darmanin m'a dit je vous donne
les télés le télégramme et je le donne
au président vérifications faites ça
fait il ya quelques jours quand même et
il avait dans les mains je ne les ai pas
reçu les présidents ne l'ont pas reçue
est-ce qu'on peut recevoir ce qu'on peut
avoir pourquoi cette chose qui était
évidente à nous donner n'est pas donné
je vous pose la question si vous pouvez
nous en lien la teneur ça sera encore lu
en direct esther benbassa dans la foulée
je vous demande vraiment de respecter
les deux minutes parce que sinon chacun
ne pourra pas s'exprimer
excuser
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet est-ce que vous tuerez vous et
vos services les conséquences de ces de
ce qui s'est passé lors de ce match real
madrid liverpool pour gérer ce genre
d'événement
autrement dans l'avenir et ce bien sûr
pour redresser l'image de la france en
matière de gestion des compétitions
sportives surtout que les jo ne sont pas
loin et deuxièmement j'ai entendu dans
les médias
des remarques sur la question de la
présence de la police devant les
antennes françaises les antennes
diplomatiques à madrid et à liverpool où
les spectateurs lésés peuvent porter
plainte
cette présence les intimide vu ce qu'ils
ont vécu devant le scad auparavant
peut-on faire autrement merci
monsieur préféré au lycée répondre
valérie boyer derrière son écran ou pas
parce qu'on peut peut-être apprendre est
ce que madame boyer et en ligne
ne semble pas fait préférant vous laisse
répondre un peu pressé de questions
écoutez monsieur le sénateur assouline
je ne sais pas ce qui est votre
expression me visait de prendre les
parlementaires pour des imbéciles
mais j'espère ne pas vous avoir donné
cette impression ce qui serait
totalement catastrophique pour moi
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous fournir le
télégramme oui bien évidemment on peut
vous le fournir donc le ministre s'y est
engagée on va vous le donne et je suis
navré si effectivement il ya un petit
délai mais il ya vraiment aucun problème
là dessus mais par contre monsieur le
sénateur à souligner permettez moi de
vous dire que je m'inscris en faux par
rapport à votre expression que dans les
manifestations nous organiserions enfin
une qu'il y aura un tourbillon organisée
par les forces de l'ordre ce n'est pas
comme ça que se passent les choses ce
n'est pas comme ça que se passe le
maintien de l'ordre dans ce pays ce
n'est pas la police qui organise les
troubles ce n'est pas la police qui est
à l'origine des difficultés non mais
pour être parfaitement clair peut-être
que j'ai mal compris madame la sénatrice
oui bien sûr on va tirer les
conséquences d'ailleurs on les a tirés
partiellement dès le match france
danemark qui n'avaient pas la même
intensité mais nous avons est très
nettement adapter notre dispositif et on
continuera à le faire comme on le fera à
chaque fois
qu'il le faudra et nous travaillons sur
les jeux olympiques avec bien sûr fort
aussi de cette expérience après vous me
dites ne pas envoyer de policiers sur
place à madrid et à et à liverpool voire
à londres moi je suis désolé nous sommes
des policiers nous n'avons que des
policiers je ne peux faire qu'avec des
policiers et je ne suis pas sûr que les
policiers fassent peur donc je pense
qu'au contraire il est tout à fait utile
qu'ils soient présents sur place il y en
a trois en angleterre 2 en espagne
les ambassades et les consulats ont
relayé donc la possibilité de porter
plainte en ligne les policiers sont au
consulat général de madrid c'est un peu
plus compliqué en angleterre parce que
malheureusement ils n'ont pas pu
disposer des locaux de locaux à
liverpool donc ils vont être la semaine
prochaine sur le site de l'ambassade à
londres mais je pense qu'ils sont tout à
fait en mesure de conseiller après les
gens s'ils veulent si les plaignants
veulent justement faire parvenir des
plaintes sans passer par
l'intermédiation des policiers c'est
tout à fait possible ils peuvent saisir
directement le parquet de bobigny et
c'est d'ailleurs en ce sens qu'il ya des
prêts plainte en ligne se fait pour être
remplie et s'ils ne veulent pas de nous
l'envoyer directement au parquet mais
surtout qu'il porte plainte et encore
une fois qu'il porte plainte sur les
difficultés qu'ils ont eue aux abords du
stade et qui nous permettent de nourrir
l'enquète car ensuite cette enquête sur
laquelle j'ai fait un article 40 auprès
du procureur qui a donc ouvert une
information à nous permettra d'avoir des
éléments sur l'analyse de la fraude est
extrêmement important ce dossier a été
confié par le procureur à la direction
de la police judiciaire et il nous faut
des éléments là dessus donc tous ceux
qui ont été confrontés à ça vraiment
porté plainte aidez nous à trouver ceux
qui sont à l'origine de ce chaos
valérie boyer puis olivier paccaud pige
horrible compte aller et boyer derrière
son écran
chaque collègue on entend des
olivier paccaud peut-être en attendant
la reine oui merci monsieur monsieur
messieurs les présidents messieurs le
ministre alors nous ne sommes ni juge me
dit refuser moi j'veux pas encore
monsieur le préfet de police pardon donc
nous ne sommes ni juge ni arbitre ni là
pour épiloguer pour reprendre votre
vocabulaire j'ai bien écouté tous les
maux vous avez utilisé il y en a
certains qui m'ont choqué comme le mot
subodorer un moment
nous sommes pas là pour brandir un
carton rouge on est là pour comprendre
éviter que ça se reproduise
c'est aussi votre votre travail moi j'ai
été frappé pendant votre propos
liminaire par le fait que vous avez
avant tout insister sur la gestion le
jour même de la fin de l'après-midi à
l'après match
vous avez insisté sur le fait vous avez
affirmé même que ça a été un échec en
tout la france toute l'europe le monde
entier le sait c'est un échec assez
criant or il faut pas être grand clerc
pour savoir que pour qu'un événement de
cette ampleur se passe bien il faut
qu'il soit bien préparée et dans votre
propos liminaire la préparation a
totalement été oublié quelques questions
de du président la faune de jérôme
durain ils sont venus - j'ai trois
questions très précises au sujet de la
préparation premièrement la notion de
match à risque lorsque le ministre est
venu il nous a parlé d'un match à risque
qui n'était pas si risqué que ça
puisqu'il nous a dit que le match nice
nantes coupe de france aux parents
étaient plus à risque et objectivement
les bras m'en sont tombés parce que
quand on connaît les supporters de
nantes peut-être que ce nice peuvent
être un peu plus tueur blanc on n'a pas
compris pourquoi le match nice nantes
était plus à risque donc si ce masque
match real liverpool n'était pas à
risque vous en avez été informée qui a
pris la décision de ne pas le classé à
risques et si ce n'est pas vous quelle
conclusion en avez-vous tiré parce que
quand un match est à risque on va
dimensionné un dispositif policier en
conséquence donc sur cette notion de
match à risque deuxième question
concernant le dispositif policier ça a
été un peu abordée
vous avez aimé le pr le ministre avait
insisté sur le fait que en ce qui
concerne le maintien de l'ordre les
effectifs a priori devait être suffisant
par contre il a lui même avoué que en ce
qui concerne lentilles criminalité ont
manqué peut-être d'hommes et le paradoxe
où la contradiction du ministre c'est de
nous dire il nous ne sommes pas dans un
match à risques mais on avait quand même
multiplier par deux le nombre d'hommes
dédié à l'anti criminalité nous a donné
chiffres 164 pour nice notre 326 hommes
pour real liverpool donc ça veut dire
quand même que vous vous doutiez qui
avait peut-être un petit problème
troisième et dernière question les
points de près filtrage et de barrage là
c'est la ministre des sports qui a fait
un espèce de petit mea culpa en disant
qu'il y avait eu un problème au niveau
de la signalétique elle a parlé de la
nécessité de mettre en place des
itinéraires de déviation ou de secours
ok vous ne l'avez dit vous-même j'ai
noté la phrase nous n'avions pas la
charge des points de filtrage or vous
êtes en charge de la sécurité vous avez
été informé de ce qui allait y avoir
comme point de près filtrage je le
suppose oui ou non
si tel est le cas puisque ça a été un
foirage lamentable pourquoi n'avez-vous
pas dès le début
réorienter les supporters et avez vous
dû attendre 19h15 ou 19h18 pour le faire
il ya eu un nombre de points de filtrage
très insuffisant vous l'avez su vous
l'avez su forcément dans vos briefing et
vous n'en avez pas tenu compte
alors nous avait dit vous as tu meures y
ait tout mais maintenant moi j'attends
vos réponses valérie boyer
madame boyer
on vous voit l'image cette fois simon ne
vous entend pas
elle n'a pas de collection alors
monsieur le comte oui merci monsieur lé
président et monsieur le
préfet une remarquer et trois questions
la remarque si je trouve que compte tenu
du fait que la grande bretagne n'est pas
dans l'espace schengen 12 aujourd'hui
disposer d'un certain nombre de signaux
faibles assez certain qui permettait de
savoir la réalité de la situation plutôt
que toutes les spéculations que nous
avons pu entendre après ce désastre eu
match trois questions d'abord je suis
très surpris lorsque vous nous dites
d'une part
il n'y aura pas de remise en cause du
schéma de maintien de l'ordre et en même
temps n'y avait pas d'autre solution que
de gaz et des personnes qui étaient
légitimement sur place bon donc si à ce
type de compte de deux difficultés est
ce qu'il ya un problème de formation
parce que doit quand même constater
qu'un certain nombre de personnes ont
été gazés alors que c'étaient d'autres
sous des formes qui absolument
contraires aux règles d'emploi des gaz
lacrymogènes donc comment en tirer ou
les conséquences sur le fond en terme de
schémas de maintien de l'ordre ou de
nécessité de formation
deuxième question vous nous dites c'est
important que l'ensemble des personnes
portent plainte pour nourrir finalement
manqué sur tout ce qui s'est passé alors
quand on regarde le formulaire qui est
téléchargeable en ligne auprès de notre
ambassade en grande bretagne finalement
rien sur ces situations en particulier
de d'action de la police en particulier
un usage de gaz lacrymogènes comment
voulez vous nourrir l'ensemble de l'
enquête ayant pas reculer réflexion sur
le schéma de maintien de l'ordre si vous
ne permettez pas aux personnes de porter
plainte sur l'ensemble des actes qui ont
pu être constatés durant cette cette
soirée donc
pouvez-vous alors que c'est un
formulaire qui est à votre en tête
changer le formulaire pour qu'ils soient
larges sur tous les actes qui ont été
effectivement constaté cette soirée là
enfin quatrième question comment est-ce
que vous expliquer la différence entre
le nombre d'interpellations relativement
nombreuses et le très faible nombre de
comparutions immédiates
est-ce que là encore vous n'avez pas pu
apporter d'éléments qui permettait de
mettre de de faire des comparutions
immédiates aux pour les personnes
interpellées merci monsieur le point que
je remercie d'avoir respecté les deux
minutes la boyer
ça voyez toujours pas connecté alors
madame boyer
bien eh bien madame de la gontrie et non
madame boyer un peu plus tard
merci messieurs les présidents au fil
des auditions
je pense qu'on peut identifier trois
séquences où des choses n'ont pas
fonctionné sur lesquels vous avez
revenus
parfois d'ailleurs avec des propos un
peu décalé par rapport à ce que ce
qu'indiquait le ministre la semaine
dernière la phase en amont on identifie
un problème d'anticipation un problème
de préparation un problème de
coordination
nous avions demandé la semaine dernière
d'avoir connaissance des comptes rendus
des réunions de préparation pour la qui
ont été tenus je n'ai pas compris si
vous voulez présider personnellement
parce que à l'évidence vous l'avez
évoqué par exemple vous n'étiez pas
comme on dit a concerné je ne sais pas
c'est pas le terme que vous avez utilisé
par l'organisation des points de
filtrage je ne sais pas de quelle mesure
la gendarmerie étaient associés à ces
réunions bref que s'est il passé dans
les réunions de préparation plusieurs
l'ont évoqué notamment le président
laffont pendant ce qu'on est au fond
c'est une conclusion me semble utile
entre
gestion de foule et maintien de l'ordre
c'est à dire que vous avez pratiqué du
maintien de l'ordre ça a donné
effectivement de l' usage de
lacrymogènes
et d'ailleurs on voit que c'est un mode
de fonctionnement qui vous est familier
et encore récemment gare de l'est il
semble que dans d'autres pays les choses
puissent être fait différemment
notamment en grande bretagne et en
allemagne semble-t-il mais en tout cas
ne croyez vous pas qu'il ya un problème
de cet ordre là sachant que
ça a été dit par plusieurs syndicalistes
notamment par david le bar secrétaire
générale du syndicat des commissaires
qui
et qu'il aimerait savoir ce qui se dit
sur les ondes radio quels étaient les
ordres c'est à dire que ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure de saisine de l'igpn pour
des gestes inappropriés disproportionnée
selon les mots du ministre notamment l'
usage des gaz lacrymogènes il semble que
les policiers n'ai pas l'intention de
porter le chapeau pour des ordres qui
leur avait été donnée ça a également été
dit par un autre syndicat ensuite le
problème après parce que depuis que nous
travaillons sur ce sujet pas que nous on
note une grande confusion dans les
explications une précipitation dans ce
que vous avez évoqué un certain flou
parce qu'effectivement deux collègues a
repris le terme subodorer bon donc moi
je depuis le début je ne sais pas où
sont ces trente mille supporters
supplémentaires mais je comprends à vous
écouter que finalement peut-être qu'il
n'était pas là bref donc c'est ça qui
crée le problème aujourd'hui c'est la
faute pendant et si le problème après la
dernière chose et j'en aurai terminé
monsieur le président vous l'avez dit de
manière très nette venez l'udepa vos
responsabilités vous dites à l'évidence
c'est un échec quelles conséquences en
tirez vous à titre personnel
merci alors on reste à une madame boyer
je crois que ça ne marche pas mieux
écouter ici si nous n'y arrivons pas
on va donner la parole aux amis
peut-être encore monsieur le préfet on
va vous donner la parole est ensuite ce
sera monsieur dessus monsieur grosperrin
monsieur le préfet
oui merci je pourrai répondre à
l'ensemble des interrogations
sur lequel les préparations
vous avez parfaitement raison dans mon
propos liminaire je n'en ai pas parlé
puisque j'ai parlé des faits et pas de
leur préparation mais à ma connaissance
il y a eu douze réunions préparatoires
4 principalement présidée par
le délégué interministériel cadeau qui
réunissait l'ensemble des acteurs qui
sont les réunions
structurantes des préparations un des
grands événements et dans lesquels se
définit l'ensemble du cadrage de mon
côté j'en ai présidé 5 au niveau de la
préfecture de police
de préparation du dispositif et ses cinq
autres ont été présidés par mon
directeur de cabinet et donc au delà de
ces deux réunions de nombreuses autres
ont eu lieu notamment la préfecture de
seine-saint-denis je peux pas vous en
donner la liste exhaustive et je pense
qu'un art au moins une dizaine d'autres
donc il ya eu de multiples réunions et
de multiples phases de préparation
mais je crois que cela n'est pas là
l'essentiel puisque l'essentiel de votre
question porte sur le fait de savoir si
la préparation était bien fait ou pas en
fait ça quand je vous ai dit c'est un
échec c'est donc je considère bien que
dans le dispositif lui-même et la façon
dont nous avions à l'aborder nous avons
une difficulté je ne sais pas comment
vous dire qu'il y avait trente quarante
mille personnes autour alors mon terme
peut-être tout à l'heure de subodore ya
peut-être une tétine malheureux tant que
je le répète une nouvelle fois mon
estimation était sur la base des
éléments fournis par les opérateurs de
trente à quarante mille personnes au
delà c'est à dire pas à entre les prêts
filtrage et le stade mais au delà c'est
à dire entre les prêts filtrage et
l'ensemble de l'extérieur de la présence
de ces personnes là voilà je suis très
clair plus des milliers de personnes
autour du stade dont le nombre a varié
et c'est bien normal puisque le but des
gens qui étaient autour était de rentrer
qu'un certain nombre sont rentrés
un nombre de plusieurs milliers de
personnes aux abords stricte du stade
qui variaient en fonction du temps ce
qui m'a inquiété et ce qui m'a amené à
prendre ses décisions étaient la
présence au delà démarrage vers
l'extérieur de ces trente à quarante
mille personnes chiffre constitué sur la
base de l'estimation des opérateurs et
de nos observations voilà je le répète
encore une fois pour être très clair je
dans la présentation qui a été faite par
le ministre sur le chiffre que j'ai
donné j'ai donné 34 me voilà des choses
sont claires alors vous me dites après
il n'existe pas oui mais alors là
il y en avait un certain nombre dans les
fans la fan zone était plein à 44 mille
personnes à paris c'était pas absolument
exact je ne compte pas ses supporters là
dans la fanzone espagnol part parce que
par construction qu'on pense que les
supporters anglais n'était pas dans la
fanzone espagnol mais c'est un
présupposé de calcul qui devrait pouvoir
se révéler exacte
mais un faisait pression sur la grille
ça dépend à quelle heure monsieur le
sénateur à quelle heure
je vous en prie
il ya la décision d'envoyer les ce que
vous alors après vous m'interrogez
monsieur le sénateur vous avez raison
sur le schéma national de maintien de
l'ordre je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
que je ne connaissais pas lorsqu'une
foule s'agglomérer lorsqu'elle se
pressaient comme ça s'est passé à la
gare de l'est d'autres moyens que les
deux que j'ai cités c'est à dire
l'utilisation de moyens intermédiaire
consistant à gaz et ce qui fait reculer
les gens puisque le gaz est désagréable
et donc il vous fait reculer ce qui est
le but du jeu coût allait charger je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
précisément et c'est ça qui se passe sur
les ondes l'instruction est donnée de ne
pas charger les gens ce qu'ils ont été
dévastateurs
dévastateur et j'assume parfaitement le
fait que le seul moyen était le gazage
je ne connais pas d'autres prêts vous
pouvez me parler de la conviction
peut-être peut-être mais je ne vous
parle pas
ce nouveau pas su nous parle du gazage
le gazage était nécessaire et j'ai
demandé qu'on gaz toc je vous dis je
l'assumé complètement après vous me
parler des gestes inappropriés qui ont
été cités par le ministre oui il y en a
eu parce que il y en a malheureusement
toujours des fonctionnaires qui se
laissent gagner par l'énervement du
moment et qui dans un certain nombre de
cas très restreint ne sont pas
professionnels à ma connaissance il y en
a deux faut dire à ma connaissance les
enquêtes sont en cours il ya deux images
notamment qui sont deux éléments qui
étaient effectivement les reproches vous
citez tout à l'heure on voir alors avec
très précis on voit un fonctionnaire
dans le stade
c'est à dire à l'intérieur des grilles
qui gaze une personne qui s'approche qui
semble être un supporter anglais parce
que juste avant quand vous regardez la
totalité images mais c'est toujours le
problème des images qui sont fournis sur
les réseaux elles ne sont pas totalement
complète quand vous regardez la totalité
des images sur les réseaux vous voyez
que dans ce fonctionnaire qui est à
l'intérieur gaz des gens qui s'étaient
introduits par l'escalier qui descend à
cet endroit là dans le dispositif du
stade pour chasser des gens et il commet
l'erreur quand une autre personne
s'approche une seconde après de la
confondre avec les gens précédent et ça
c'est pas professionnelle ne sera pas
parce qu'ils ne devaient pas se tromper
de cette façon là puis un autre cas sur
un des barrages voilà donc je ne nie pas
qu'il y ait eu comme malheureusement
dans toutes les opérations que nous
menons des gestes inappropriés mais deux
gestes inappropriés peut-être deux
signalements à l'igpn par rapport au
nombre de fonctionnaires engagés et la
durée du dispositif
quand j'estime que ça prouve une chose
ça prouve la qualité des fonctionnaires
ça prouve leur efficacité et ça prouve
leur déontologie
ai je vraiment j'insiste là dessus et je
ne laisserai pas ces fonctionnaires est
remis en cause je voulais dit tout à
l'heure si vous devez vous en prendre à
quelqu'un vous en prenez à moi
je suis là pour ça bon
suit ensuite
[Musique]
les
le classement des matches
ce match
n'était pas un match à risque qui
n'était pas classé en tant que tel dans
la hiérarchie des classements comme
étant cesser ces matches à risques comme
nice nantes qui était de niveau 4 celui
là était de niveau 3 le ministre l'a
rappelé je crois que les choses étaient
parfaitement clair ben non pas
incompréhensible assez logique en fait
c'est assez normal ça soit classé comme
ça puisque par des filets
mais la note de narp la note de la dnlh
a beaucoup de qualités mais elle ne
prédit pas l'avenir si vous voulez je
suis d'accord moi non plus je vous le
confirme sur les sénateurs mais si
jamais vous le faites n'hésitez pas à
nous le dire la prochaine fois
ce qui manquait comme information assez
stratégique c'est l utilisation massive
de faux billets alors oui vous pouvez me
dire vous pouvez me faire le reproche
vous n'avez pas anticiper une
utilisation massive de faux billets
c'est exact je n'ai pas anticiper une
utilisation massive de faux billets je
m'attendais à des faux billets je ne
m'attendais pas un volume de cette
nature de faux billets sur nos
dispositifs tels qu'ils sont constitués
bien évidemment ils sont en entités raw
sur les prés filtrage les prêts barrage
est appelée sera tout à l'heure parce
qu'il y a les gens du stade moi je pense
à l'estadi mc peut-être inappropriés
comme expression enfin les gens
embauchés par le stade qui contrôlent
l'est qui font les pré contrôle de
billet émis un évidemment quand on sent
que ces gens sont en difficulté on se
met derrière on est en train de regarder
des terroristes en attendant qu'ils
viennent et en s'occupant d'autres
choses quand ça s'est passé sur les
présages immédiatement nous nous sommes
déployés derrière pour appuyer les
agents du stade donc nous ne sommes pas
dans ne sommes pas dans dans une
passivité absolue à regarder ce qui se
passe parce que c'est pas notre sujet
notre sujet c'est bien évidemment la
gestion de la foule la décision que j'ai
prise c'était de ne pas maintenir à tout
prix le dispositif policier qui a été
derrière le pré filtrage parce que
d'abord les agents de l'esj agents du
stade avait craqué s'en allait et que si
je maintenais par la force strictement
nécessaire
le prêt barrages il y avait un drame
mais on est dans des appuis dans des cas
comme ça puisque la gestion de foule
relève bien évidemment la responsabilité
policière je n'ai jamais dit quoi que ce
soit d'autre en la matière ou si je les
dis je leur précise ici voilà je ne sais
pas si j'ai malheureusement oublié des
choses le formulaire oui le formulaire
qui mériterait d'être complété c'est un
formulaire standard effectivement qui
est le formulaire de de la pré pré pré
plainte en ligne peut-être est-il
inadéquate
je faisais et je vais réfléchir là vous
me prenez un peu de course et notre
formulaire de pré plainte en ligne
utilisé d'ailleurs sur l'ensemble du
territoire sont fehrer de ma part je
crois que c'est le même partout j'ai
pris la précaution de le faire traduire
ça me paraissait nécessaire après c'est
pas une précaution ça va de soi c'est le
bon sens de le traduire en anglais en
espagnol
fallait-il un formulaire spécifique au
regard du dispositif
je reconnais qu'il est un peu compliqué
il est à la française nous sommes un
pays de droit écrit donc on a beaucoup
de cases de trucs à cocher avec se taire
je vais je vais réfléchir à ça et je
vous dirai ce moment l'ancien sénateur
bien alors cinq dernières années après
il faut quant à
laquelle
oui alors nous allons continuer et
ensuite il appartiendra au préfet de
conclure et doit répondre cinq dernières
séries puissions rentrer
alors oui il ya plusieurs questions qui
arrive si on peut on doit vendre à
toutes les questions mais dans l'ordre
s'il vous plaît alors il y aura
si vous me permettez il y aura
une série de questions je préfère faudra
effectivement répond à la question qui
était posée par madame de la gontrie
quand on vous en donnera la parole
je complète ce que disait monsieur le
comte sur le questionnaire peut-être
parce que nous l'avons eu nous l'avons
observé le lieu dit des infractions le
stade des pas mentionné peut-être que
c'est plus parlant pour les supporters
anglais ou espagnol
de cibler le stade de france où vont les
choses seront plus plus précise me
semble-t-il il ya peut-être sur les
nature des infractions en particulier
les infractions à caractère physique qui
ne sont pas mentionnés on a beaucoup de
choses sur le vol sur mes mais pas sur
des agressions hautement physique on va
dé la parole à monsieur thomas do su
ensuite à monsieur grosperrin puis
monsieur benarroch puis monsieur
kerrouche et madame brulin et même là
pardon et ensuite je préfère on vous
redonne à la parole thomas dessus merci
messieurs les présidents mais je vais
revenir une nouvelle fois sur l' usage
des gaz lacrymogènes ce que votre
réponse
ce n'est clairement pas satisfaisante la
seule réponse de dire il n'y a pas
d'alternative et on tourne la page
ne ne convient pas et là dessus sur la
doctrine de menthe alors que vous êtes
en désaccord avec le ministre qui la
semaine dernière à votre place dés
expliqué qu'il envisageait un changement
de doctrine dans l' usage de ces gaz
notamment dans l'accueil des événements
sportifs en prévision évidemment des
jeux olympiques et donc j'aimerais bien
avoir un avis un peu plus étayée sur ce
désaccord est sûre peut-être l'ouverture
d'un changement de doctrine à cet usage
puisque bon on a compris que quand on
participe à une manifestation
quelle qu'elle soit on a compris qu'il
fallait se préparer a respiré des gaz
lacrymogènes maintenant quand on va
assister à un événement sportif ou
peut-être aussi l'envisager quand on
attend le bus on l'a vu ce week-end il
faut aussi l'envisager est-ce que
parfois vous ne trouvez pas qu'il ya un
abus au delà des deux images qu'on a pu
voir et qu'on était filmé les deux
malheureuses agents ont été filmés dans
ce mail usages et donc vont peut-être
subir la foudre d'une une enquête
administrative est donc pour aller plus
loin pour imaginer un autre face de
notre façon de de pouvoir gérer ces
événements sportifs moi j'aimerais
comprendre est-ce que les sommations qui
ont été faits avant l'usagé ces gaz
lacrymogènes ont été faites en anglais
est ce qu'un dialogue a été possible
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de témoignages
de supporters de liverpool qui sont
adressés à des agents qui n'ont pas eut
obtenu de réponse notamment quand ils
étaient compressés dans les points de
filtrage est ce que nos agents de police
ou au moins 1 2 les responsables sur
place par les anglais est ce que cette
envisagée monsieur le comte là là là
évoqué la formation de nos agents là
dessus pour pouvoir accueillir un public
international lors des grands événements
sportifs je vous remercie
jacques grosperrin
merci c'est le président
monsieur le préfet le président buffet
tout à l'heure à nous à dire en
préalable qu'ils avaient besoin
on sent bien que vous êtes seul
responsable opérationnel vous l'avez
fort bien dit et à trop le dire on sent
aussi que vous ôtez la responsabilité du
président une les intérieurs le
président la république qui a accepté ce
match alors qu'on sait qu'il fallait 10
du mois qu'il a faim en trois mois on
sent bien également en creux que vous
êtes prêts en tant que haut
fonctionnaire assumer complètement
être sur l'autel pour être sacrifié
néanmoins lorsque vous le dites que
c'est pas un match à risques c'est grave
parce que les supporters de liverpool ce
sont justement connu pour se déplacer en
masse et sans billet et sur le fait
qu'ils étaient régulièrement de
s'infiltrer vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que voulaient les faire reculer mais
avant de les faire reculer il faut
éviter les phares avant c'est donc le
problème du filtrage se pose moi j'ai
trois questions la première si vous nous
dit que je ne savais pas ce qui s'est
passé dans côte des billets est ce qu'il
y a eu un problème de coordination entre
la sécurité du stade et les forces de
l'ordre car nous savions que les
supporters allaient essayer de rentrer
et de franchir les grilles deuxième
question certains parcs de
dysfonctionnement dans la chaîne de
commandement y aurait-il pu et je n'ose
le croire des consignes contradictoires
de intervenir sur les fauteurs de
troubles et troisième et dernière
question vous encourager chacun chaque
supporter a porté plainte est ce que ces
encouragements le sont également de
déposer plainte en direction de la
police dans le cas des gaz lacrymogènes
si vous ne répondez pas ce question
s'entendre et votre gêne exprimée sur
ces faits tube oh mercy
derrière son écran
oui bonjour merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le préfet la plupart des
questions ont déjà été posées mais
quitte à passer et à faire passer les
parlementaires pour des gens qui ont
besoin de reposer plusieurs fois les
mêmes questions vis répéter on quitte je
posais la question suivante de nouveau
votre démonstration semble tendre a
montré qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres
possibilités
après les deux décisions vous aviez
prise de leur image de la reprise sont
aussi beaucoup au centre air comfort
cela vous les avez pas centré n'avait
pas d'autre solution que de gaz et déjà
qu'ils n'avaient aucune raison de l'être
et ce qui me paraît stupéfiant c'est
qu'aucune vous nous dites que rien ne
laissait penser que vous seriez amené à
le faire et que en fait si on se
retrouvait dans la même situation dans
six mois dans un an dans deux ans dans
trois ans vous referiez la même chose
donc je repose un peu la même question
que mon collègue thomas d'hossus n'y at
il pas d'autres alternatives aujourd'hui
envisagée dans la doctrine du maintien
de l'ordre et dans les possibilités
d'intervention que celle de gaz et des
gens qui n'y sont pour rien éric
kerrouche et ensuite céline brulin
oui merci messieurs merci passion
président mais je préfère vous avez
insisté sur votre rôle dans les choix
stratégiques et qui qui ont été faits
pour
ce match mais vous nous avez aussi mis
l'accent sur le fait que vous aviez des
indices laissant accroire que il y
aurait une concentration aux abords du
stade dont thomas j'ai une question qui
sont directement liés à ce sujet la
première d'après les informations que
nous avons vous disposiez pour cet
événement de trente trois unités de
forces mobiles ce qui à ma connaissance
représente à peu près entre 30 et 33 %
des effectifs de l'ensemble de nos
forces nationales et vous n'avez choisi
d'en déployer uniquement que dix sur le
stade de france
pourquoi ce sont ce choix stratégique
alors que vous saviez manifestement que
des gens extérieurs allait se concentrer
sur le stade la deuxième question
c'est que il semble que vous ayez fait
le point de déployer la brigade de
répression de l'action violente sur le
stade alors que manifestement elle n'est
pas le plus adapté pour ce genre
d'événement au détriment par exemple des
crs comment expliquez-vous là encore ce
choix je vous remercie
si lyn brulin et enfin alexandra burke
chiot fonte un
arrêt
céline brulin
si nous l'avons pas elle arrive
alexandra bon show frontin se prépare
il faut allumer ce votre micro sur
collègues comme paulin
allez-y
on vous entend pas alexandra bauer
chaudfontaine en attendant
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet nous sommes donc tous conscients
1,6 à l'enchaînement de
dysfonctionnements qui a mené à ce chaos
dans la france serait bien passée à
quelques encâblures des jeux olympiques
rayonnement de notre pays crédibilité
aussi de nos autorités et puis remise en
question de notre capacité à accueillir
des événements d'une telle ampleur c'est
autant conséquences qui abîme et qui
préoccupe bien sûr l'esprit nos
concitoyens mais aussi de nos voisins
européens
l'absence d'anticipation une véritable
stratégie de maintien de l'ordre en est
il me semble en tout cas à l'origine
alors lors de l'audition du ministre de
l'intérieur il ya quelques jours je
l'interrogé sur la stupéfaction de voir
aux abords du stade entre la sortie du
rer et l'entrée du stade la vente
d'alcool à la sauvette et de denrées
alimentaires aussi dans des conditions
d'ailleurs d'hygiène déplorables pire
encore en ce qui concerne la lutte
contre la menace terroriste sachez que
je n'ai pas été fouillés à l'entrée et
le ministre de l'intérieur d'ailleurs à
avouer qu'au bout d'un moment ni les
billets ni les personnes ont été
contrôlées le ministre de l'intérieur a
annoncé vos décisions avait sauvé des
vies probablement je crois aussi elle
aurait pu en supprimer d'autres
dernière tentative avec céline brulin
alésia collègues
manifestement ça ne passe pas je posais
deux dernières questions si vous me le
permettez monsieur le préfet de
questions précises parce que nous sommes
là aussi pour lever tout un tas de
d'informations vraies ou fausses qui
auraient été
des données ces derniers jours
je veux revenir sur la fausse
billetterie puisqu'au début en tout cas
dans la compréhension qu'on a pu avoir
on a eu l'impression que c'était entre
30 et 40 mille faux billets maintenant
il apparaît assez clairement que ce
n'est pas 30 à 40000 faut oublier vous
l'avez bien précisé qu'il y avait des
gens qui s'étaient présentés aux abords
du stade sans sens en biais est-ce qu'on
a une estimation de la fosse billets
qu'est ce que ça représente
il avance à ne pas être qu'une
estimation mais qu'est ce que ça
représente cette fausse billetterie
deuxième élément sur les 300 à 400
individus les avait qualifiées d' un
désir à bhl qui ont
commis des agressions et
pendant et après 2 après le match dans
la note que vous avez transmis au
ministre de l'intérieur le lendemain du
match vous préciser que ces 300 à 400 je
pense que c'est les mêmes étaient des
jeunes issus des quartiers sensibles de
seine-saint-denis
est-ce que quinze jours après
l'événement vous avez des précisions à
nous apporter sur les 300 à 400
personnes indésirables
ses parents de sa parole je voudrais
peut-être me faire le porte parole si je
puis dire
de madame boyer qui n'a pas réussi à
s'exprimer pour dépression manifestement
technique mais questions qui sont les
suivantes je les interprète pour les
réduire
pourquoi finalement dit elle il n'y a
pas eu plus d'anticipation sur la
gestion
de la délinquance qui que l'on connaît
ou qu'on imagine autour du stade c'est
sa première question cette deuxième
question
pourquoi il y avait t-il autant de
mineurs isolés la presse faisant état de
cette situation là sachant que par
définition ils sont a priori connu de
nos services
enfin mais je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
sur le questionnaire la notion d agréer
de viser les agressions physiques ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour l'instant elle le
reprend et sa dernière question pourquoi
si peu de comparution immédiate
il n'y a pas eu de caméras pour
corroborer les témoignages on a évoqué à
ce sujet je compléterai par une dernière
question
comment s'est-il passé ce que la police
a continué son action lorsque les gens
sont repartis dans les transports en
commun puisqu'on nous dit par témoignage
principalement qu'il ya eu dans les
transports en commun des agressions donc
comment a été géré aussi cette situation
là merci monsieur le préfet vous avez la
parole et janicot collègues que nous
lèverons ensuite la séance
merci messieurs les présidents alors
madame de la gontrie oui vous avez
raison merci de vous soucier de ma
situation personnelle
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit le sujet
mais je vous répondrai en privé si vous
le souhaitez
on préfère les y répondre mais quelle
importance ma situation personnelle mais
enfin franchement je suis un haut
fonctionnaire
je suis révocable and tom tous les
mercredis c'est quoi votre problème à la
réunion elle vous a été posée et vous me
donnerez acte que j ai répondu elle a
été posée vous me donnerez là que j ai
répondu alors
par rapport à toutes les questions sur
les gaz lacrymogènes etc etc je redis ce
que j'ai dit je ne connais pas d'autres
moyens que les gaz ou la charge
la doctrine peut bien évidemment évoluer
si c'est souhaité qu'on ne casse pas
mais il va falloir qu'on charge pour
repousser une foule donc moi je suis pas
très partisan de cette deuxième option
mais voilà je le dis en tant que
technicien du sujet
j'ai pas non plus une préférence absolue
mais il me semble que c'etait en la
matière ce qu'il fallait faire les
sommations bien sûr été fait bien sûr
que non elles n'ont pas été faites en
anglais nos textes ne perd 1,10 pas de
faire notre nation en anglais pour faire
des sommations en anglais ont été tes ne
pas faire de sommation et bien
évidemment à ce moment là certains
auraient reproché de ne pas avoir fait
destination puisque dans une langue
étrangère et non prévue par les codes
oui bien sûr qu'on a fait des annonces
en anglais par le dispositif de haut
parleurs à très forte puissance qui
s'appelle des hyper spike c'est des
choses qui sont extrêmement fortes en
termes de densité de décibels et on a
fait toute une série d'annoncés pour
demander aux gens de s'écarter mais
force est de constater que ces annonces
n'ont pas été suivies d'effet les
problèmes de coordination avec les
organisateurs josé expliquer les
réunions qu'il y avait eu la façon dont
les choses s'étaient passées
je vois je
quand ça se passe mal bien évidemment
vous est fondé à dire que c'est par un
défaut de préparation oui bien
évidemment
après je vous ai dit que c'est un échec
et que on aurait pu sans doute faire les
choses différemment si on s'était
attendu à une fraude aussi massive que
celle là oui je ne peux pas vous dire le
contraire est toujours est il que ça
n'était pas dans ce que nous avions
envisagé du moins à ce niveau de
massification de la fraude peut toujours
faire mieux est-ce que l'instruction
était donnée de ne pas intervenir sur
les fauteurs de troubles c'est pas le
genre d'instruction condamne dans la
police s'est par contre donné une
instruction effectivement je suis très
clair là dessus de ne pas interpeller de
supporters avec des faux billets entre
guillemets puisque d'abord on n'était
pas sûr que ce soit des faux billets
simplement le dispositif technique ne
fonctionnait pas on en a déduit et
d'ailleurs on étend les autorités
sportives en ont déduit que c'était des
faux billets mais moi sur le moment je
n'avais pas d'élément prouvant que
c'était une infraction un délit et en
tout état de cause il me semblait qu'on
pure opportunité ce n'était pas le sujet
du moment de procéder à ces
interpellations car nous avions mieux à
faire donc oui des instructions ont été
données en ce sens mais pas sur les
fauteurs de troubles c'est à dire en
l'occurrence sur les délinquants et sur
ce qu'ils se comportaient de manière à
contrefaire des
commettre des délits
porté plainte contre la police mais bien
évidemment si les supporters anglais et
espagnol le faire ils peuvent le faire
alors vous me demandez juste de le
prévoir dans le formulaire si je
comprends bien
je pense que les choses sont assez
claires et que je sois ne pose pas de
problème si effectivement je le dis
publiquement puisque vous me donner la
chance de m'exprimer publiquement et de
m'adresser ainsi au delà de nos
concitoyens français aux supporters
anglais espagnol s'il considère que des
actes de police ont été commis de façon
irrégulière mais bien évidemment qui
nous le signale et nous donnerons les
suites nécessaires
referais je la même chose sur les gaz je
crois vous avoir répondu oui je referais
la même chose
parce que encore une fois je pense que
c'est le c'était le plus adapté sur la
répartition des iufm
la gare de l'est aussi je pense que
c'était approprié de le faire encore une
fois monsieur le sénateur le guide le
fil rouge de mon action depuis le sous
préfet de police c'est d'éviter les
morts et les blessés graves
j'ai la chance de les avoir évité
j'ai la chance les avoir évité ce qui
aurait pu se passer beaucoup plus mal
avec des morts depuis les trois ans et
trois mois que je suis ici mai 68 ya eu
des morts au maillage et je n'y a pas eu
de mort à paris voilà je ne nie pas que
les choses sont parfaites mais
j'aimerais quand même que de temps en
temps on rappelle ce que sont des
réalités historiques je sais monsieur le
sénateur à swing combien vous êtes
attaché à l'histoire sur les braves
alors là aussi
laisser finir le préfet
je ne m'occupe pas du transport
collectif
j'aimerais faire seul la barre merci
monsieur le président alors les braves
ils sont tellement de répéter ça que les
braves ne seraient pas des unités
spécialisées à l'égal des crs et des
escadrons de gendarmes mobiles mais
c'est faux les bras sont des unités
spécialisées peut-être plus entraînés
que celle que je viens de citer vous dit
peut-être parce que je ne veux froisser
personne mais d'un haut niveau de
technicité et propre à la préfecture de
police c'est pas une invention de ma
part j'ai simplement inventé l'acronyme
le modus operandi mais ses effectifs dit
des compagnies d'intervention existe à
la préfecture de police depuis la nuit
des temps c'est à dire des unités de
forces mobiles spécialisées préfecture
de police pour des raisons qui tiennent
à l'histoire je le rappelais tout à
l'heure et aux faits et à ce qu'elle la
région capitale
donc les braves sont à même et son est
spécialisée dans l'intervention en
matière d'ordre public donc il n'était
pas surprenant lorsque nous avons eu
besoin de deux renforts de réserve peut
faire intervenir
c'était parfaitement justifiée 1 ce sont
des unités d'élite derrière quand une
fois moi je suis à la disposition de vos
commissions messieurs les présidents si
vous voulez assister par exemple un
entraînement des braves des compagnies
d'intervention alors souvent la
confusion je sais d'où elle vient
confusion elle vient pas de la
connaissance du dispositif police parce
que c'est pas forcément la spécialité
absolue des uns et des autres elle vient
de l'appellation parce qu'on prend dans
ce qu'on appelle une compagnie
d'intervention et pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ont la chance d'être élus de régions
en dehors de la région ile-de-france le
nom des compagnies d'intervention c'est
les unités de sécurité publique qui se
forment pour des des opérations d'ordre
public donc effectivement il ya cette
confusion mais c'est pas parce qu'il ya
cette appellation similaire que la
technicité l'expérience n'est pas très
fort dans les unités constituées
embrasse alors l'alcool à la sauvette
oui nous sommes nous avons eu beaucoup
beaucoup de 4 sauvette
on nous en avons interpellé neuf c'est
assez difficile d'intervalle interpellé
dès sauvette en raison de leur extrême
mobilité et en ce moment je suis en
train de de concentrer une
expérimentation d'interpellation de
sauvette sur le champ de mars sur
lesquels nous avons une grosse présence
du soviet c'est des gens qui vendent ça
peut aller de boissons sont de marche
son lit tour eiffel pouvoir des maillots
de supporters il y en avait énormément
mais encore une fois
les interpellés étaient absolument
nécessaires mais dans la hiérarchie des
incidents ce qui nous a préoccupé dans
les interpellations c'est d'abord en
faire sur les agressions et sur les
violences aux personnes c'était sale
absolue priorité alors qu'est ce qui se
passe ensuite dans les comparutions
immédiates je vous disais tout à l'heure
il va falloir voir avec les parquets
concernés sur ce qui s'est passé au
niveau des comparutions mais très
souvent est ce qu'on observe dans des
mouvements de foule de cette nature
c'est qu'on peut pas reprocher à la
justice de ne pas déferrer de ne pas
emmener les gens en comparution
immédiate parce que le problème que nous
avons c'est la rédio la rédaction des pv
d'interpellation quand vous êtes dans un
moment de cette nature c'est à dire
d'une intensité policière gendarmes
extrêmement forte
il faut rédigé le pv d'interpellation de
la personne qui a été interpellée le
contexte etc et c'est vrai que quand il
ya urgence c'est souvent mal fait
c'est pas un reproche que je fais à aux
hommes que j'ai sous mon commandement
fameuse et aux hommes que j'ai souvent
commandement mais c'est une réalité
d'expérience très franchement ils ont
vraiment quelque chose à faire et les pg
est en mal fait quand ça arrive devant
les magistrats à juste titre ils nous
disent mais votre truc tient pas debout
c'est un des problèmes qu'on a dans les
manifestations qu'on a depuis 2000 15,5
on a identifié à partir de 2015 alors
que la nature des manifestations changé
voyez c'était même avant mon arrivée
tout n'est pas dû à ma présence à la
préfecture de police
c'est une des difficultés qu'on a c'est
de documenter les précisément les
conditions d'une interpellation et du
reproche de l'infraction ou du délit qui
est commune on a expérimenté plusieurs
méthodes et qu'on n'avait pas déployé au
stade de france je reconnais des agents
spécialisés en appui de ses éléments
d'intervention d'ailleurs en quelque
sorte des greffiers du dispositif qui
permette d'aider très rapidement le
fonctionnaire à faire son pv
d'interpellation mais c'est vrai pour
les raisons que j'ai évoquées tout à
l'heure ils n'étaient pas déployés à
cette occasion est assez
vraisemblablement nos pv n'étaient pas
totalement totalement bien fait bon je
ne recommence pas sur la les 30-40 milch
espère même si j'ai bien compris que je
n'avais pas convaincu tout le monde
j'espère avoir été clair oui mais je
suis toujours convaincu monsieur le
sénateur par nature je suis un homme de
conviction et donc je ne vois pas très
bien pourquoi je ne raconterai des
choses de cette nature mais enfin bon
moi je vous dis ce que nous avons vu ce
que nous avons constaté les éléments
voilà après vous pouvez tout à fait
légitimement les contester mais ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas le sujet sur le
président du fai vous aviez posé une
dernière question que je suis confus
gelé mal noté si vous pouviez me l'a
rappelé une dernière question de parler
d' accompagner dernière question posée
était celle de quelle a été l'action de
la police pour les personnes vous le
supposez supporters qui ont repris les
transports en commun trèbes ensuite
sachant que nous remontent des
informations aux termes desquels des
agressions ont été commises à ce moment
là notamment
lorsque nous avons essayé de faire c'est
que le dispositif étaient organisées de
la façon suivante dispositif d'ordre
public sur le périmètre des prêts
barrage est un dispositif de sécurité
publique qui était en dans les gares et
en périphérie des gars c'est à dire dans
les parties extérieures par exemple
quand on prend la ligne 13 au nord de la
ligne 13 était notre dispositif de
sécurité publique entre la gare et ce
qui était la fan zone espagnol puisque
c'est là que
on pensait que les actes de délinquance
interviendrait quand on a levé nos
barrages et repliée notre dispositif
d'ordre public sur le stade puis à
l'intérieur du stade les
délinquants sont descendus de cette zone
là et sont rentrés sur les cheminements
des supporters et nous avons à ce moment
là faire redescendre notre dispositif de
sécurité publique mais il n'était pas
appuyé par notre dispositif d'ordre
public c'est à dire que la présence sur
les prés barrages il était à l'évidence
moins dissuasif c'est ça qui s'est passé
alors vous pouvez venir certes si vous
aviez été trois fois plus ce serait
beaucoup mieux fonctionner oui bien
évidemment
mais la combinaison des événements qui
jusqu'à présent faisait qu'un dispositif
de sécurité publique c'est-à-dire
sécurité publique j'entends par là vous
disiez tout à l'heure anti criminalité
mais c'est anti délinquance ces reculs
les gens d'ordre public ne s'occupe de
la délinquance que lorsqu'elle est
commise dans le cadre de la manoeuvre
dendre public c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
est violent qui casse et c'est là les
équipes interpelle alors publics etc ans
est en sécurité publique c'est bondé
faire habituelle de délinquance qui est
dans nos dispositifs stade c'est l'appui
des deux unités des deux dispositifs qui
permettait l'efficacité est
effectivement à partir du moment où des
dispositifs d'ordre public étaient à
l'intérieur du stade même s'il en est
sorti sur la fin du match mais à ce
moment là il était englué dans le départ
des supporters a été à l'évidence moins
efficace et en fait c'est ce qui s'est
passé donc là aussi on en a tiré des
conséquences sur
ce que nous devons faire lors de
systèmes de cette nature c'est à dire
avoir des réserves d'intervention de
sécurité publique en capacité de
sécuriser les retours ces voix là c'est
la combine c'est que notre appui
traditionnel ne s'est pas fait du goût
du coup on avait moins de solidité dans
la dans l'aspect sécurité publique
permet d'assister parce que quand je
n'ai pas entendu votre réponse sur les
300 à 400 indésirables
quelle est l origine de ces de ces
personnes oui je me sens
moi je ne sais pas s'ils étaient 105 me
poupart
il ya les 300 à 400 personnes qui ne
semblait pas une des supporters mais
faut que je fasse attention à ce que je
subodore si j'ai bien compris non c'est
ce que vous écrivez c'est surtout ça
c'est parce que c'était dans la note
c'est pour ça que je vous posais la
question j'ai écrit lh2
seine-saint-denis parce que il à terre
en seine-saint-denis maintenant vous
dire si vous voulez si votre question on
va être très franc si votre question est
ce que ce sont des gens des cités autour
du stade je ne peux pas dire une chose
pareille je n'en sais rien
est ce que c'est un type de population
délinquante qu'on rencontre en seine
saint denis oui ça arrive mais on en
rencontre également dans le nord de
paris ce type de
2,2 de profil voilà mais je ne peux pas
les traces et vous avez raison dans ma
dodge indiqué de seine-saint-denis mais
je vous prête franchement
bien leur y avait là dedans des mineurs
non-accompagnés ça c'est un grand
classique un qui est effectivement temps
en temps dans la gestion
relève qu'en dehors de leurs actes de
délinquance des collectivités locales
bien merci monsieur le préfet de votre
présence ce matin et des réponses aux
questions qui ont été posées nous allons
chers collègues levé c'est audition vous
rappelant qu'à 14h30 nous reprenons une
aux travaux en auditionnant la
fédération française de football merci
voilà pour cette audition au sénat du
préfet de police de paris didier
lallement qui a répondu aux questions
des sénateurs sur le fiasco de
l'organisation de la finale de la ligue
des champions le 28 mai dernier à paris
à saint denis au stade de france
dixièmement qui assume l'échec de
l'organisation de cet événement en
termes de sécurité mais ledit certaines
de ces décisions ont permis de sauver
des vies notamment la décision de lever
les barrages de près filtrage des
supporters qui ont donné l'accès aux
abords du stade à toute la foule didier
lallement assume également l'utilisation
de gaz lacrymogènes par la police sur
les familles avec enfants de supporters
il le dit c'était le seul moyen de faire
reculer la foule pour ne pas justement
chargé la foule voilà pour cette
audition du préfet de police de paris
sachez que cet après-midi et bien les
sénateurs continuent leur audition sur
ce fiasco du stade de france des
positions que vous pouvez suivre dès 15h
sur public sénat avec d'abord les
dirigeants de la fédération française de
football qui vont être entendus la
fédération française qui est responsable
de l'organisation de cet événement et
puis ensuite ce sera au tour du maire de
liverpool d'être auditionnés par les
sénateurs le maire de liverpool qui est
très virulent contre l'accueil des
supporters britanniques ce soir là je
vous souhaite une très bonne journée sur
public sénat
[Musique]
le camping-car raconte l'europe la
guerre la paix et la prospérité
la société industrielle les loisirs
le camping-car raconte le bonheur de mon
enfance et la manière dont on était
heureux à la fin du xxème siècle
m
j'ai grandi en camping car et le
camping-car m'a fait grandir
en camping car une histoire de nos
vacances un documentaire de andres girac
demain à 22h sur public sénat
[Musique]
notre invité cette semaine et membre de
l'académie française première femme élue
secrétaire perpétuel ardente défenseuse
de la langue française ou peut-être
devrais-je dire défenseur ce sera
justement elle de nous le dire pourtant
le français n'était pas sa langue
maternelle jusqu'à 4 ans et demi elle ne
parlera que russe comment devient ton
alors gardien d'une langue qui n'est pas
la sienne à l'origine hélène carrère
d'encausse nous répond dans un monde un
regard les entretiens de public sénat
remet un monde un regard avec hélène
carrère d'encausse demain à 19h sur
public y en a
[Musique]
depuis quelques semaines quand il
termine sa journée d'infirmiers libéral
pierre césarini retrouve une maison un
peu plus animée que d'habitude
d
alors
détour
pour les orioles
[Musique]
avec sa femme cécile installé depuis 20
ans dans ce milieu rural ils ont décidé
d'accueillir une famille ukrainienne
réfugié en france
il est
évident et de santé est ce la
femme attendu mais avait des fils
électriques qui dépassait du coup elle a
tout rasé donc alexander s'est précipité
pour réparer ça avant que j'arrive on
parle thinel grande gueule avec les
mains mais on y arrive toujours puis
bahia ou de gaza si qui s'expriment
kouakou vraiment très correctement en
anglais mais mieux que moi mais bon du
coup 1 81% on arrive à se comprendre
c'est le débrouille du langage y ont
installé un destin dans le secret
[Musique]
pour la famille andré f originaire de
kiev la fuite du pays à ressembler à
celles de millions d'autres ukrainien
précipité en abandonnant sa vie d'avant
au pays
la guerre a démarré des bombes ont
commencé à tomber à proximité de chez
nous on a alors commencé à rassembler
des affaires au cas où et après quelques
jours on a décidé de quitter kiev pour
une ville un peu plus à l'écart des
bombardements à l'ouest
les amis de mon père qui nous hébergeait
nous ont dit qu'ils avaient des amis qui
vivait en france ils nous ont alors
demandé pourquoi vous ne riez pas en
france on ya réfléchi et finalement on
s'est dit que c'était sans doute mieux
une arrivée dans le trièves à une heure
de l'agglomération grenobloise qui leur
fera un répit bien mérité
ici on se sent presque comme à la maison
et surtout ce n'est pas dangereux donc
c'est vraiment bien on voit des gens qui
sont qui sont obligés de se déplacer en
nombre
avec un courage énorme de partir d'où
ils sont sans savoir où ils vont enfin
voilà nous un signe a pas un élan de
solidarité à ce moment là je ne sais pas
quand il pourra y avoir donc pour nous
là c'était assez naturel de s'inscrire
dans un processus
dans un processus d'accompagnement
d'accueil de ces de ces personnes la
langueur une évidence pour la famille
suzanne unis qui a déjà accueilli des
exilés syriens notamment et pierre est
aussi engagé dans la commune de minces
1300 habitants dont il est maire depuis
j'ai envie de dire je suis pas
schizophrène e lemaire et citoyen c'est
la même personne voilà j'ai pas je suis
pas mère de telle heure à telle heure et
citoyen le reste du temps versa a fait
c'est la même personne et c'est
effectivement le même élan qui fait que
la municipalité et l'équipe municipale
que que je dirige et dans cette erreur
là est il moins choix d'éléments de
cette équipe là
ni
[Musique]
s'il s'est engagé personnellement le
maire demain ça aussi embarqué sa
commune dans l' aventure comme un peu
partout en france savent il a d'abord
organisé une collecte pour l'ukraine est
ici elle a dépassé toutes les attentes
[Musique]
du coup le seul espace culturel qui est
juste en face de la mairie et c'est
cette pierre etaix a servi de lieu de
stockage il restait encore du matériel
volontairement mais cette pièce était
vraiment en plus parfois que trois pages
ça arrive et ça arrivait à savait plus
où m on a des absences étaient sans
facoise immense enfin pendant quasiment
les deux semaines avant le départ du
convoi le tri et été commencé parce
qu'il fallait effectivement avait partir
dans des cartons bien fermé mais à
chaque fois j'avais des rappels ont
fermé un carton qui avait la valeur
d'autres cartons qui arrivait face
c'était c'est un flux continu c'était
moins flou continue face à cet afflux
pierre césarini accompagnés de bénévoles
a finalement décidé d'acheminer
personnellement la collecte à la
frontière ukrainienne
allez viens
c'est plus un périple à travers l'europe
pour apporter l'aide humanitaire et
ensuite ramené des réfugiés